Herzlich willkommen, liebe Besucherinnen und Besucher von TOP-Hörbücher. Schön, dass ihr da seid.
Wusstet ihr, dass 50.000 Kinder und Jugendliche in Deutschland lebensverkürzend erkrankt sind?
Sie und ihre Familien sind besonderen, vor allem auch finanziellen Belastungen ausgesetzt.
Die Deutschen Kinderhospitestienste haben es sich zur Aufgabe gemacht, diesen Kindern und ihren Familien zu helfen.
Dazu allerdings brauchen sie unsere Hilfe.
Als Botschafter der Deutschen Kinderhospitestienste ist es mir ein Herzensanliegen, euch um eure Unterstützung zu bitten.
Sämtliche Beteiligte an der Produktion dieses Hörbuchs, so auch das Studio, in dem wir alle unsere Hörbücher aufnehmen, verzichten auf ihr Honorar.
Daher gehen sämtliche Einnahmen dieses Hörbuches zu 100 Prozent an die Deutschen Kinderhospitestienste.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr natürlich zusätzlich auch noch etwas spenden.
Das könnt ihr hier direkt auf unserem Kanal bei TOP-Hörbücher machen.
Oder ihr geht auf die Homepage der Deutschen Kinderhospitestienste dort, findet ihr eine IBA-Nummer und dann könnt ihr darspenden.
Übrigens findet ihr dort auch jede Menge nützliche Hinweise und Erklärungen über diesen Verein.
Den Link zu dieser Homepage haben wir euch eingeblendet in der Beschreibung unter dem Video.
Und eins noch bitte, teilt dieses Video so oft ihr könnt, damit diese Botschaft möglichst viele Menschen erreicht.
Habt ganz herzlichen Dank.
Jetzt bleibt mir nur noch übrig, euch eine schöne und friedvolle Advents- und Weihnachtszeit zu wünschen.
Und einen fantastischen Rutsch in einem hoffentlich und vor allem gesundes neues Jahr.
Wir wünschen euch ganz viel Spaß mit dem kleinen Prinzen.
Der kleine Prinz von Antoine de Saint-Exuperie, gelesen von Albusceva.
Für Leon Werth.
Ich entschuldige mich bei den Kindern dafür, dieses Buch einem Erwachsenengewitt mit zu haben.
Ich habe aber eine wirklich gute Entschuldigung.
Dieser Erwachsene ist der beste Freund, den ich auf der Welt habe.
Und ich habe noch eine andere Entschuldigung.
Dieser Erwachsene kann alles verstehen.
Sogar Bücher für Kinder.
Und ich habe noch eine dritte Entschuldigung.
Dieser Erwachsene lebt in Frankreich.
Er hat Hunger und ihm ist kalt.
Er muss getröstet werden.
Wenn all diese Entschuldigungen nicht gelten, dann möchte ich dieses Buch dem Kind widmen, dass dieser Erwachsene einst war.
Alle Erwachsenen waren einmal Kinder.
Aber nur wenige erinnern sich daran.
Deswegen muss ich meine Widmung noch einmal korrigieren.
Für Leon Werth, als er ein kleiner Junge war.
Kapitel 1.
Als ich sechs Jahre alt war, habe ich in einem Buch über den Urwald, das den Titel Erlebte Geschichten trug,
das erste Mal ein wunderschönes Bild gesehen.
Es zeigte eine Riesenschlange, die ein wildes Tier verschlingt.
Im Buch hieß es, Riesenschlangen verschlingen ihre Beute in einem Stück, ohne sie zu zerkauen.
Danach können sie sich nicht mehr bewegen und halten sechs Monate lang Verdauungsschlaf.
So habe ich viel über Dschungelabenteuer nachgedacht.
Und dann gelang mir mit einem Farbstift meine Zeichnung Nummer 1.
Sie sah so aus.
Ich zeigte mein Meisterwerk den Erwachsenen und habe sie gefragt, ob sie vor meiner Zeichnung Angst hätten.
Sie haben mir geantwortet, warum sollte man vor einem Hut Angst haben?
Dabei war auf meinem Bild gar kein Hut.
Es zeigte eine Riesenschlange, die einen Elefanten verdaut.
So habe ich also das Innere der Schlange gezeichnet, um es den Großen verständlich zu machen.
Immer muss man ihnen alles erklären.
Meine Zeichnung Nummer 2 sah so aus.
Die Erwachsenen haben mir geraten, mich nicht mehr mit offenen oder geschlossenen Riesenschlangen zu beschäftigen,
sondern mich stattdessen mehr für Geografie, Geschichte, Mathe und Grammatik zu interessieren.
So gab ich mit sechs Jahren meine vielversprechende Malerkarriere auf.
Derart entmutigt war ich vom Misserfolg meiner Zeichnungen Nummer 1 und Nummer 2.
Erwachsene verstehen nie etwas von ganz allein.
Und für die Kinder ist es anstrengend, ihnen immer alles zu erklären.
So musste ich einen anderen Beruf finden und ich lernte Flugzeuge zu steuern.
Ich flog ein bisschen in der Welt herum und es stimmt, dabei half mir die Geografie.
Auf den ersten Blick konnte ich China von Arizona unterscheiden.
Das ist sehr nützlich, wenn man sich in der Nacht verirrt hat.
So hatte ich im Laufe meines Lebens mit vielen ernsthaften Leuten zu tun.
Ich habe viel bei Erwachsenen gelebt und ich habe sie ganz aus der Nähe betrachtet.
Aber meine Meinung über sie hat sich deshalb nicht sonderlich verbessert.
Wenn ich einen Traf, der mir ein bisschen heller vorkam,
dann testete ich ihn mit meiner Zeichnung Nummer 1, die ich immer bei mir trug.
Ich wollte wissen, ob er wirklich schlauber.
Aber immer erhielt ich die Antwort, es ist ein Hut.
So sprach ich weder von Riesenschlangen, noch vom Urwald oder von Sternen.
Ich liess mich auf ihn ein.
Ich sprach über Bridge, Golf, über Politik und Krawatten.
Und der Erwachsene war zufrieden, auf einen so vernünftigen Mann zu treffen.
Kapitel 2.
So lebte ich allein, ohne jemanden, mit dem ich wirklich hätte sprechen können,
bis ich vor sechs Jahren eine Panne in der Wüste Sahara hatte.
Irgendetwas an meinem Motor war kaputt gegangen.
Und weil ich weder ein Mechaniker noch Passagiere bei mir hatte,
bereitete ich mich darauf vor, die schwierige Reparatur ganz allein vorzunehmen.
Dabei ging es für mich um Leben und Tod.
Ich hatte Trinkwasser für knapp acht Tage.
Am ersten Abend schlief ich im Sand ein, tausende Meilen entfernt von besiedeltem Gebiet.
Ich war viel abgeschiedener als ein Schiff brüchiger mitten im Ozean.
So könnte euch vorstellen, wie überrascht ich war,
als ich bei so einem Aufgang von einer leisen, lustigen Stimme geweckt wurde.
Und die saute, bitte, zeichne mir ein Schaf.
Wie bitte? Zeichne mir ein Schaf.
Ich sprang auf, als wäre ich vom Blitz getroffen worden.
Ich rieb mir die Augen und schaute genau hin.
Und ich sah ein außergewöhnliches kleines Kerlchen, das mich ernst betrachtete.
Hier das beste Porträt, das ich später von ihm zustande brachte.
Aber natürlich ist meine Zeichnung weit weniger bezaubernd als das Original.
Das ist nicht meine Schuld.
Die Großen haben mich von meiner Malerkarriere abgebracht,
als ich sechs Jahre alt war,
sodass ich nichts zu Zeichnen gelernt hatte als geschlossener und offener Riesenschlangen.
Ich schaute also voller Verwunderung mit aufgerissenen Augen auf diese Erscheinung.
Vergess nicht, ich war tausend Meilen entfernt von jeglichem besiedelten Gebiet.
Dabei schien mir das kleine Kerlchen weder verirrt, noch totmüde,
weder hungrig oder durstig, noch totängstlich.
Es wirkte ganz und gar nicht wie ein Kind, verloren inmitten der Wüste,
tausend Meilen entfernt von jeglicher Zivilisation.
Als ich mich endlich gefasst hatte, sagte ich,
aber was machst du denn hier?
Da wiederholte er ganz sacht,
als handle es sich um eine sehr ernst zunehmende Angelegenheit.
Bitte, zeichne mir ein Schaf.
Bei etwas so beeindruckend Rätselhaftem wag man nicht zu widersprechen.
So absurd es mir erschien,
holte ich tausend Meilen entfernt von jeglicher Zivilisation meinen Farbstifter vor,
ein Blatt Papier und ein Füller.
Ich erinnerte mich daran, dass ich vor allem Geografie, Geschichte, Mathematik und Grammatik erlernt hatte
und so sagte ich schlecht Gelaun zu dem kleinen Männchen, das ich nicht zeichnen könne.
Er antwortete mir, das macht nichts, zeichne mir ein Schaf.
Weil ich niemals ein Schaf gezeichnet hatte,
malte ich einfach eines der zwei Bilder, die ich beherrschte, jenes von der geschlossenen Riesenschlange.
Und ich war verblüfft, als der kleine Kerl mir antwortete,
Nein, nein, ich will keinen Elefanten in einer Riesenschlange.
Eine Riesenschlange ist sehr gefährlich und ein Elefanten nimmt viel Platz weg.
Bei mir ist es ganz klein.
Ich brauche ein Schaf. Zeichne mir ein Schaf.
So habe ich also gezeichnet.
Er schaute aufmerksam zu und dann,
Nein, dieses ist schon sehr krank. Zeichne ein anderes.
Und ich zeichnete.
Mein Freund lächelte lieb und sagte nachsichtig,
Siehst du, das ist kein Schaf, das ist ein Hamel, das hat Hörner.
So machte ich einen neuen Versuch.
Aber er wurde wie die vorherigen abgelennt.
Das ist zu alt. Ich möchte ein Schaf, das lange lebt.
Da ich mein Motor endlich auseinander bauen wollte,
schluderte ich ungeduldig dieses Bild hin und sagte,
Das hier ist eine Kiste, das Schaf ist da drin.
Aber ich war sehr überrascht,
als ich sah, wie das Gesicht meines jungen Kritikers strahlte.
Genauso wollte ich es.
Glaubst du, man braucht viel Gras für dieses Schaf?
Warum?
Weil es bei mir ganz klein ist.
Es reicht ganz sicher aus. Ich habe dir ein ganz kleines Schaf gegeben.
Er beugte den Kopf über die Zeichnung.
Na, so klein auch nicht.
Schau, es ist eingeschlafen.
Und so habe ich den kleinen Prinzen kennengelernt.
Ich brauchte lange, um zu verstehen, woher er kam.
Der kleine Prinz stellte mir viele Fragen, aber schien meine zu überhören.
Es waren zufällig ausgesprochene Worte, durch die mir nach und nach alles klar wurde.
Als er das erste Mal mein Flugzeug sah,
ich zeichne mein Flugzeug hier nicht, denn das ist viel zu schwierig für mich.
Da fragte er mich, was ist dieses Ding?
Das ist kein Ding. Es fliegt.
Das ist ein Flugzeug. Das ist mein Flugzeug.
Ich war stolz ihm mitzuteilen, dass ich fliegen konnte, aber er rief,
wie, du bist vom Hemel gefallen?
Ja, erwiderte ich Bescheiden.
Aha, das ist lustig.
An der kleine Prinz brach ihn ein herzliches Lachen aus, das mich sehr verärgerte.
Ich wünsche, dass man ernst nimmt, was mir an Unhalt zustößt.
Dann fügte er hinzu, also kommst du auch aus dem Hemmel?
Von welchem Planeten stammst du?
Plötzlich wurde mir klar, was es mit seiner Anwesenheit auf sich haben könnte,
und ich fragte schnell, du stammst also von einem anderen Planeten?
Aber er antwortete mir nicht.
Er nickte nur sanft, während er mein Flugzeug betrachtete.
Auf diesem Ding kannst du nicht von sehr weit herkommen.
Und er verfiel in eine lange Träumerei.
Er holte das Schaf aus seiner Tasche und bewunderte lange Zeit seinen Schatz.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wie sehr es mich beschäftigte,
was er mir über die anderen Planeten schon halb anvertraut hatte.
So strengte ich mich an mehr darüber zu erfahren.
Woher kommst du, kleiner Kerl?
Wo ist dein Zuhause?
Wohin willst du mein Schaf mitnehmen?
Er antwortete mir nach einem nachdenklichen Schweigen.
Das Grute an der Kiste, die du mir gegeben hast,
ist, dass sie ihm als Haus dienen wird in der Nacht.
Ganz bestimmt.
Und wenn du nett bist, gebe ich dir auch einen Strick, um es nachts festzubinden.
Und einen Pflok.
Dieser Vorschlag schien den kleinen Prinzen zu schockieren.
Es festbinden? Was für eine merkwürdige Idee.
Aber wenn du es nicht festbindest, kann es überall hingehen und sich verlaufen.
Erneut brach mein Freund in Lachen aus.
Aber wohin soll es denn deiner Meinung nach gehen?
Egal wohin, einfach geradeaus.
Im ernsten Ton bemerkte der kleine Prinz.
Das macht nichts. Es ist so klein bei mir.
Und vielleicht ein bisschen traurig fügte er hinzu.
Geradeaus konnte man nicht besonders weit.
Kapitel 4.
So lernte ich eine zweite wichtige Sache.
Sein Heimatplanet war kaum größer als ein Haus.
Das wunderte mich nicht.
Ich wusste genau, dass es neben den großen Planeten,
wie der Erde, dem Jupiter, dem Mars oder der Venus,
denen wir Namen gegeben hatten,
noch hunderte anderer Planeten gibt,
die manchmal so klein sind,
dass man sie selbst durch ein Teleskop kaum erkennen kann.
Wenn ein Astronom einen von ihnen entdeckt,
so gibt er ihm eine Nummer anstelle eines Namens.
Er nennt ihn z.B. Asteroid 3251.
Ich habe ernstzunehmende Gründe zu glauben,
dass der Heimatplanet des kleinen Prinzen
der Asteroid B612 ist.
Nur ein einziges Mal, im Jahre 1909,
hat ein türkischer Astronom diesen Asteroiden
durch sein Fernrohr gesehen.
Seine Entdeckung hatte er
bei einem internationalen Astronomie-Kongress vorgeführt.
Aber wegen seiner traditionellen Tracht
hatte ihm niemand glauben wollen.
So sind die Erwachsenen.
Zum Glück für den Asteroiden B612
zwang ein türkischer Diktator,
sein Volk unter Androhung der Todesstrafe,
sich nach europäischer Art zu kleiden.
So wiederholte der Astronom
in sehr eleganter Kleidung seine Vorführung
im Jahre 1920.
Und dieses Mal waren alle seiner Meinung.
Wenn ich euch diese Details
über den Asteroiden B612 erzähle
und seine Nummer verraten habe,
dann wegen der Erwachsenen.
Erwachsene Lieben zahlen.
Erzählt ihr ihnen von einem neuen Freund,
stellen sie euch nie Fragen über das Wesentliche.
Sie sagen niemals, wie klingt seine Stimme?
Was sind seine Lieblingsspiele?
Sammelt er Schmetterlinge?
Sie fragen euch, wie alt ist er?
Wie viele Geschwister hat er?
Wie viel wiegt er?
Wie viel verdient sein Vater?
Damit glauben sie ihn zu kennen.
Erzählt ihr den Erwachsenen,
ich habe ein schönes Haus aus roten Ziegelstein gesehen,
mit Geranien vor den Fenstern
und Tauben auf dem Dach.
Dann gelingt es ihnen nicht,
sich dieses Haus vorzustellen.
Man muss ihnen sagen,
ich habe ein Haus gesehen,
das 100.000 Frauen wert ist.
Dann rufen sie erfreut.
Oh, wie schön.
Wenn er ihnen also sagt,
der Beweis dafür,
dass es den kleinen Prinzen wirklich gegeben hat,
liegt darin, dass er bezaubernd war,
dass er lachte und dass er sich ein Scharf wünschte.
Wenn man ein Scharf möchte,
beweist das doch, dass es einen gibt.
Dann werden sie mit den Schultern zucken
und euch wie ein Kind behandeln.
Sagt er ihnen aber,
sein Heimatplanet ist der Asteroid B612.
Dann werden sie überzeugt sein
und euch in Ruhe lassen mit ihren Fragen.
So sind sie.
Man darf ihnen deswegen nicht böse sein.
Kinder müssen mit Erwachsenen nachsichtig sein.
Aber wir, die das Leben verstehen,
lachen natürlich über Zahlen.
Eigentlich hätte ich die Geschichte viel lieber
wie ein Märchen begonnen.
Ich hätte gerne gesagt,
es war einmal ein kleiner Prinz,
der lebte auf einem Planeten,
der war kaum größer als er selbst
und er brauchte einen Freund.
Für all jene, die das Leben verstehen,
würde das viel richtiger klingen.
Denn ich mag es nicht,
wenn man mein Buch so leichtfertig liest.
Es betrübt mich, von diesen Erinnerungen zu erzählen.
Es ist schon sechs Jahre her,
dass mein Freund mit seinem Scharf verschwunden ist.
Wenn ich versuche, ihn hier zu beschreiben,
dann deswegen, um ihn nicht zu vergessen.
Es ist traurig, einen Freund zu vergessen.
Nicht jeder hatte schon mal einen Freund.
Ich könnte wie die Großen werden,
die sich nur noch für Zahlen interessieren.
Doch deswegen habe ich mir ja den Farbkasten
und die Stifte gekauft.
Es ist schwierig, in meinem Alter
wieder mit dem Zeichnen anzufangen,
wenn man nie etwas anderes versucht hat,
als mit sechs Jahren eine geschlossene
und eine offene Riesenschlange zu malen.
Ich werde natürlich versuchen,
die Abbildungen möglichst wahrheitsgetreu zu zeichnen.
Aber ich bin nicht sicher, ob ich es schaffe.
Dass eine Bild gelingt,
dass andere hat schon keine Endlichkeit mehr.
Auch mit der Größe liege ich ein bisschen falsch.
Hier ist der kleine Prinz zu groß, da ist er zu klein.
Auch zögere ich bei der Farbe seiner Kleidung.
Ich versuche es mal so und mal so,
eben so gut es geht.
Ich werde mich bestimmt bei einigen viel wichtigeren Details täuschen.
Aber das muss man mir nachsehen.
Mein Freund gab mir nie irgendwelche Erklärungen.
Er glaubte vielleicht, ich sei ihm ähnlich.
Aber ich weiß nicht,
wie man durch Kisten breiter hindurch Schafe sieht.
Vielleicht bin ich doch schon ein bisschen wie die Erwachsenen.
Ich muss älter geworden sein.
Kapitel 5.
Jeden Tag lernte ich etwas über den Planeten,
über den Abschied, über die Reise.
Das kam nach und nach durch zufällige Überlegungen.
Auf diese Weise erfuhr ich am dritten Tag
von der Tragödie mit den Affenbrotbäumen.
Auch das geschah dank eines Schafs,
denn plötzlich fragte mich der kleine Prinz
wie von einem schlimmen Zweifel überkommen.
Es ist doch wahr, dass scharfe Sträucher fressen, oder?
Ja, das ist wahr.
Ha, da bin ich froh.
Ich verstand nicht, warum es so wichtig war,
dass scharfe Sträucher fressen.
Aber der kleine Prinz fügte hinzu.
Also fressen sie auch Affenbrotbäume?
Ich wies den kleinen Prinzen darauf hin,
dass Affenbrotbäume keine Sträucher seien,
sondern Bäume, so groß wie Kirchen.
Und selbst wenn er sich eine ganze Herde
Elefanten mitnehmen würde,
so würde die Herde nicht an einen einzigen Affenbrotbaum heranreichen.
Über die Idee mit den Elefanten
musste der kleine Prinz lachen.
Man müsste sie übereinander stapeln.
Aber dann bemerkte er Weise.
Bevor die Affenbrotbäume wachsen,
sind sie doch erst klein.
Das stimmt.
Aber warum möchtest du, dass deine Schafe
die kleinen Affenbrotbäume fressen?
Er antwortete.
Schon gut.
Wir werden ja sehen,
als ging er es um eine Selbstverständlichkeit.
Und es kostete mich ganz schön viel Intelligenz,
um dieses Problem allein zu verstehen.
Es gab auf dem Planeten des kleinen Prinzen
wie auf jedem Planeten natürlich
gute und schlechte Pflanzen.
Daher gab es auch gute Samen von guten Pflanzen
und schlechte Samen von schlechten Pflanzen.
Aber Samen sind unsichtbar.
Sie schlafen verborgen in der Erde,
bis aus einer Laune heraus ein Korn erwacht.
Es regt sich und schiebt ganz schüchter noch
einen entzückenden, kleinen,
ganz harmlosen Hallen der Sonne entgegen.
Handelt es sich um den Trieb eines Radieschens
oder einer Rose,
dann kann man ihn so wachsen lassen, wie es ihm gefällt.
Aber wenn es sich um Unkraut handelt,
dann muss man die Pflanze umgehend herausreißen,
sobald man sie entdeckt hat.
Nun gab es schreckliche Samenkörner
auf dem Planeten des kleinen Prinzen.
Es waren die Samen der Affenbrotbäume.
Der Boden des Planeten war davon übersät.
So einen Affenbrotbaum wird man nicht mehr los,
wenn man sich zu spät darum kümmert.
Er befällt den ganzen Planeten.
Er durchbohrt ihn mit seinen Wurzeln.
Und wenn der Planet zu klein ist
und die Affenbrotbäume zu zahlreich werden,
dann sprengen sie ihn.
Das ist eine Frage der Disziplin,
sagte mir später der kleine Prinz.
Wenn man morgens aus dem Bad kommt,
dann muss man auch den Planeten säubern.
Man muss sich dazu zwingen,
die Affenbrotbäume regelmäßig herauszureißen,
sobald man sie von den Rosen unterscheiden kann,
denen sie in jungem Alter sehr ähneln.
Es ist eine nervige, aber ziemlich einfache Arbeit.
Und eines Tages riet er mir,
mich doch zu bemühen,
eine schöne Zeichnung zustande zu bringen,
damit die Kinder bei mir zu Hause es sich einprägten.
Wenn sie eines Tages reisen,
sagte er mir, kann Ihnen das helfen.
Manchmal passiert nichts Schlimmes,
wenn man eine Pflicht erst später erledigt.
Aber wenn es sich um Affenbrotbäume handelt,
dann ist es immer eine Katastrophe.
Ich kannte einen Planeten,
auf dem ein Vollpels wohnte.
Erde drei Sträucher einfach nicht beachtet.
Nach den Beschreibungen des kleinen Prinzen
zeichnete ich diesen Planeten.
Ungern klinge ich wie ein Moral-Apostel.
Aber wie gefährlich Affenbrotbäume sind,
ist so wenig bekannt.
Und die Risiken für jemanden,
der sich auf einen Asteroiden verirrt,
sind so groß,
dass ich einmal eine Ausnahme mache.
Ich sage, Kinder,
Vorsicht vor Affenbrotbäumen.
Um meine Freunde vor dieser unbekannten Gefahr zu warnen,
der sie ebenso wie ich bislang stets knapp entkommen waren.
Für die Erkenntnis aber hatte sich gelohnt.
Ihr fragt euch vielleicht,
warum gibt es in diesem Buch
nicht noch andere so großartige Bilder
wie jenes mit den Affenbrotbäumen?
Die Antwort ist einfach.
Ich habe es versucht, aber es ist mir missglückt.
Beim Zeichnen der Affenbrotbäume hatte ich jedoch das Gefühl,
es sei wirklich dringend.
Kapitel 6
Ach, kleiner Prinz,
nach und nach habe ich so dein kleines, trauriges Leben verstanden.
Lange Zeit blieb dir nur die Lieblichkeit
der Sonnenuntergänge, um dich zu zerstreuen.
Dieses Detail erfuhre ich am Morgen des vierten Tages,
als du mir sagst,
ich mag Sonnenuntergänge.
Lass uns seinen Sonnenuntergang anschauen.
Aber man muss warten.
Worauf denn warten?
Na, darauf, dass die Sonne untergeht.
Du wirkt es zunächst sehr überrascht,
aber musst es dann selbst lachen.
Und du hast zu mir gesagt,
ich glaube immer noch, ich sei bei mir.
Tatsächlich.
Wenn es in den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika Mittagszeit ist,
das weiß ja jeder,
dann geht in Frankreich die Sonne unter.
Man müsste innerhalb einer Minute nach Frankreich gelangen können,
um den Sonnenuntergang dort zu sehen.
Leider ist Frankreich viel zu weit entfernt.
Aber auf deinem kleinen Planeten,
da musstest du nur den Stuhl um ein paar Schritte verrücken.
Und schon siehst du die Abenddämmerung, wann immer du willst.
Einmal habe ich die Sonne 43 Mal untergehen sehen.
Und ein wenig später fügtest du hinzu.
Meist du, wenn man sehr traurig ist,
dann liebt man Sonnenuntergänge.
Also warst du an dem Tag mit den 43 Mal besonders traurig?
Aber der kleine Prinz antwortete nicht.
Kapitel 7.
Am fünften Tag kam ich, wie der einmal dank des Schafes,
hinter ein weiteres Geheimnis im Leben des kleinen Prinzen.
Ohne Umschweife fragte er mich gerade heraus,
als pflücke er die Frucht eines lange im stillen gereiften Problems.
Wenn ein Schaf sträucherfrist, dann also auch Blumen.
Ein Schaf rist alles, was es findet.
Selbst wenn die Blumen Dornen haben?
Ja, selbst Blumen mit Dornen.
Wozu dienen dann diese Dornen?
Ich wusste es nicht.
Unterdessen war ich mit dem Versuch beschäftigt,
an meinem Motor einen Bolzen zu lockern, der zu festgezogen war.
Ich war sehr besorgt, denn langsam schien mir meine Panne doch sehr ernst.
Und das zu neigegehende Trinkwasser ließ mich das Schlimmste befürchten.
Wozu sind die Dornen gut?
Der kleine Prinz ließ nie von einer Frage ab, wenn er sie einmal gestellt hatte.
Ich war von meinem Bolzen abgelenkt, und so antwortete ich einfach irgendetwas.
Die Dornen sind zu überhaupt nichts Nutze.
Die Blumen lassen sie nur aus Gemeinheit wachsen.
Oh!
Aber nach einem Augenblick stille, da erwiderte er verärgert.
Ich glaube dir nicht.
Blumen sind schwach.
Sie sind leichtgläubig.
Sie schützen sich nur so gut sie können.
Mit den Dornen glauben sie, sehen sie gefährlich aus.
Ich antwortete nichts.
Sondern sagte mir in diesem Augenblick, wenn dieser Bolzen nicht nachgibt,
muss ich ihn mit dem Hammer herauslösen.
Wieder unterbrach der kleine Prinz meine Überlegungen.
Und du glaubst das diese Blumen?
Aber nein, aber nein, ich glaube gar nichts.
Ich habe nur irgendetwas geantwortet.
Ich muss mich hier um wichtige Dinge kümmern.
Er schaute mich erstaunt an.
Um wichtige Dinge.
Er sah mich an, wie ich den Hammer in der Hand
und mit ölverschmierten Händen über einem Ding hing,
das ihm ausgesprochen hässlich erscheinen musste.
Du sprichst weder Erwachsenen.
Das beschämte mich etwas.
Aber er fügte noch unerbittlich hinzu.
Du verwechselst alles.
Du bringst alles durcheinander.
Er war wirklich sehr aufgebracht.
Er schüttelte sein goldenes Haar im Wind.
Es gibt einen Mann mit hochhuttem Kopf.
Er hat noch nie den Duft einer Blume gerochen.
Er hat noch niemals einen Stern betrachtet.
Er hat noch niemals jemanden geliebt.
Nie hat er etwas anderes getan, als Zahlen zu addieren.
Und den ganzen Tag wiederholt er so wie du.
Ich bin ein ernstzunehmender Mann.
Ich bin ein wichtiger Mann.
Und damit brüstet er sich voller Hochmut.
Er ist kein Mann.
Er ist ein Pilz.
Ein was bitte? Ein Pilz!
Der kleine Prinz war vor Zorn nun ganz bleich geworden.
Seit tausenden Jahren lassen Blumen Dornen wachsen.
Seit tausenden Jahren fressen die Schafe die Blumen trotzdem.
Und es soll nicht wichtig sein,
verstehen zu wollen, warum sie sich so mühsam Dornen wachsen lassen,
die zu gar nichts Nutze sind.
Dieser Krieg zwischen Schafen und Blumen
soll nicht wichtig sein?
Dass es nicht ernstzunehmender und wichtiger
als die Berechnungen eines dicken, rotbäckigen Mannes ist?
Und wenn ich eine Blume kenne,
die es nur einmal auf dieser Welt gibt,
nirgends außer auf meinem Planeten.
Und wenn nun ein kleines Schaf eines Morgens
diese Blume einfach so mit einem Biss vernichten kann,
ohne zu wissen, was es tut,
dann soll das nicht wichtig sein?
Er lief ganz ruhd an und fuhr dann fort.
Wenn jemand eine Blume liebt,
die es auf zig Millionen Sterne nur ein einziges Mal gibt,
dann reicht ihm ein Blick zu ihnen hinauf,
um glücklich zu sein.
Er sagt sich, irgendwo dort ist meine Blume.
Aber wenn das Schaf die Blume frisst,
so ist es für ihn so, als sein ganz plötzlich
alle Sterne verschwunden.
Und das soll nicht wichtig sein?
Mir brachte er nicht hervor.
Er fing auf einmal an zu schluchzen.
Die Nacht war hereingebrochen.
Ich hatte mein Werkzeug beiseitegelegt,
mein Hammer, mein Bolzen,
der Durst und der Hunger erschien mir auf einmal albern.
Es gab auf einem Stern, auf einem Planeten,
auf meinem Planeten der Erde einen kleinen Prinzen zu trösten.
Ich nahm ihn in die Arme.
Ich wiegte ihn.
Ich sagte zu ihm,
deine geliebte Blume ist nicht in Gefahr.
Ich werde deinem Schaf ein Malkorb zeichnen.
Ich zeichne dir eine Rüstung für deine Blume.
Ich wusste wirklich nicht, was ich sagen sollte.
Ich fühlte mich sehr schlecht.
Ich wusste nicht, wie ich ihm näher komme,
wie ich ihm beistehen konnte.
Das Land der Tränen ist voller Geheimnisse.
Kapitel 8.
Schon bald lernte ich jene Blume besser kennen.
Auf dem Planeten des kleinen Prinzen hatte es schon immer Blumen gegeben.
Sehr einfache, verziert nur mit einem Kranz von Blütenblättern.
Sie waren kaum zu bemerken und stürten niemanden.
Sie sprossen eines Morgens aus dem Gras
und am Abend waren sie wieder verschwunden.
Doch eines Tages keimte ein Spross aus einem Samen,
von dem keiner wusste, woher er kam.
Und der kleine Prinz überwachte ganz genau diesen kleinen Halm,
der nicht so aussah wie die anderen.
Das konnte eine neue Art des Affenbrotbaumes sein.
Doch bald schon hörte der Strauch aufzuwachsen
und eine blütige Di heran.
Der kleine Prinz erzog, wie eine enorme Knoss bekeimte.
Und er fühlte, es würde etwas zauberhaftes daraus erwachsen.
Doch die Blume wurde und wurde nicht fertig damit,
sich im Schutze ihrer grünen Kammer heraus zu putzen.
Sorgfältig wälte sie ihre Farben aus.
Langsam zog sie sich an
und rückte ihre Blütenblätter eines nach dem anderen zurecht.
Sie wollte nicht ganz zerknittert herauskommen wie die Monblumen.
Sie wollte nur in voller Schönheit aufblühen.
Hoja, sie war sehr eitel.
So hatte sie tagelang vor dem Spiegel gestanden.
Und dann eines Morgens, als die Sonne aufging, hatte sie sich gezeigt.
Und sie, die sich so sorgfältig herausgeputzt hatte, sagte gähnend,
Oh, ich bin doch ganz verschlafen.
Sie müssen mich entschuldigen.
Ich bin noch ganz zerzaust.
Der kleine Prinz konnte seine Bewunderung nicht mehr verbergen.
Wie schön sie sind.
Das ist wohl wahr.
antwortete die Blume sanftmütig.
Und ich bin im gleichen Moment geboren wie die Sonne.
Der kleine Prinz ahnte, dass sie nicht sonderlich bescheiden war.
Aber sie war dennoch so reizend.
Es ist bald Zeit zum Frühstücken.
fügte sie kurz darauf hinzu.
Hätten sie die Güte an mich zu denken?
Und ganz verwirrt, holte der kleine Prinz eine Kanne mit frischem Wasser, um die Blume zu gießen.
Bald schon nervte sie ihn mit ihrer scheuen Eitelkeit.
Eines Tages zum Beispiel, als sie den kleinen Prinzen von ihren vier Dornen erzählte,
hatte sie zu ihm gesagt,
Die Tiger soll nur kommen mit ihren Krallen.
Auf meinem Planeten gibt es keine Tiger, erwiderte der kleine Prinz.
Und außerdem fressen Tiger kein Gras.
Ich bin kein Gras, antwortete die Blume sanft.
Entschuldigen sie mich.
Vor Tigern fürchte ich mich nicht, aber jeder Luftzug ist mir eng aus.
Hätten sie nicht einen Wandschirm?
Grauen vor Luftzug.
Das sind schlechte Aussichten für eine Blume, bemerkte der kleine Prinz.
Diese Blume ist äußerst kompliziert.
Stellen sie mich am Abend einfach unter eine Glasglocke.
Es ist sehr kalt bei ihnen, das ist schlecht eingerichtet.
Da, wo ich herkomme, aber sie unterbrach sich.
Sie war ja als Samen gekommen.
Sie konnte gar nichts von den anderen Welten kennen.
Beschämt, dass sie sich selbst mit einer so einfallslosen Lüge enttarnt hatte,
hustete sie zwei oder dreimal, damit sich der kleine Prinz schuldig fühlte.
Dieser Wandschirm?
Ich wollte ihn eben holen gehen, aber sie sprachen mit mir.
Wieder hatte sie sich gezwungen zu husten, um ihm ein schlechtes Gewissen zu machen.
So hatte der kleine Prinz, obwohl er durch seine liebeguten Willens war, rasch an ihr gezweifelt.
Er hatte unwichtige Worte allzu ernst genommen und war dabei sehr unglücklich geworden.
Ich hätte nicht auf sie hören sollen.
Vertraute er mir eines Tages an.
Auf Blumen sollte man niemals hören.
Man muss sie anschauen und einatmen.
Meine ließ meinen Planeten duften.
Aber ich konnte mich nicht darüber freuen.
Diese Geschichte mit den Krallen, die mich der Art Zorn nicht gemacht hatte,
hätte mir eigentlich zu Herzen gehen sollen.
Und weiter vertraute er mir an.
Ich war nicht in der Lage, es zu verstehen.
Ich hätte sie nach ihren Taten und nicht nach ihren Worten beurteilen sollen.
Sie spendete mir Duft.
Sie strahlte für mich.
Niemals hätte ich fliehen dürfen.
Hinter den armseligen Boshaftigkeiten hätte ich ihre Zärtlichkeit erkennen müssen.
Blumen sind voller Widersprüche.
Aber ich war zu jung, um sie lieben zu können.
Kapitel 9.
Ich glaube, für seine Flucht diente ihm ein schwarm wilder Zugvögel.
Am Tag seiner Abreise räumte er sein Planeten auf.
Die noch aktiven Vulkanen fegte er sorgfältig sauber.
Er besaß zwei aktive Vulkanen.
Die waren nützlich, um sein Frühstück aufzuwärmen.
Er besaß auch einen erloschenen Vulkan.
Aber er sagte sich, man weiß ja nie, so fegte er auch den erloschenen Vulkan.
Wenn Vulkanen sauber gefegt sind,
brennen sie nur ganz leicht und gleichmäßig, ohne auszubrechen.
Vulkanische Ausbrüche sind so wie Kaminfeuer.
Wir auf der Erde sind viel zu klein, um unsere Vulkanen abzufäken.
Darum bereiten sie uns so viele Sorgen.
Auch die letzten Triebe der Affenbrotbäume riss der kleine Prinz betrübt heraus.
Er dachte, er würde nie wiederkommen.
Aber all diese vertrauten Handgriffe erschienen ihm an diesem Morgen sehr angenehm.
Und als er die Blume zum letzten Mal goss und sie unter ihre schützende Glasglocke stellen wollte,
da überkam ihn das Bedürfnis zu weinen.
Adieu, sagte er zu der Blume.
Aber sie antwortete ihm nicht.
Adieu, wiederholte er.
Die Blume musst du husten.
Aber das lag nicht an ihrer Erkältung.
Ich bin dumm gewesen, sagte sie schließlich.
Bitte verzei mir, versuche glücklich zu sein.
Er war überrascht darüber, keine Vorwürfe zu hören.
Er blieb ganz erstaunt stehen, die Glasglocke in den Händen.
Diese ruhige Liebenswürdigkeit verstand er nicht.
Aber ja, ich liebe dich, sagte die Blume.
Ich bin schuld, dass du es nicht bemerkt hast.
Es ist nicht wichtig.
So warst eben so dumm wie ich.
Versuche glücklich zu sein.
Leg die Glasglocke weg.
Ich möchte sie nicht mehr.
Aber der Wind, so erkältet bin ich gar nicht.
Der nächtliche Wind wird mir gut tun.
Ich bin eine Blume.
Aber die Insekten, ich muss schon zwei oder drei Raupen aushalten,
wenn ich die Schmetterlinge kennenlernen will.
Sie sollen so wunderschön sein.
Wer wird mich ansonsten besuchen?
Du wirst weit fort sein.
Was die großen Tiere angeht, habe ich keine Angst.
Ich habe meine Dornen.
Leicht gläubig zeigte sie ihre vier Dornen.
Dann fügte sie hinzu.
Trödel nicht so rum, das ist ärgerlich.
Du hast entschieden vorzugehen.
Mach dich auf den Weg.
Sie wollte nicht, dass er sie weinen sieht.
Sie war eine so stolze Blume.
Kapitel 10.
Er befand sich in der Gegend der Asteroiden 325, 326, 327, 328, 329 und 330.
So begann er ihnen einen Besuch abzustatten, um sich zu beschäftigen und sich schlau zu machen.
Auf dem ersten lebte ein König.
Der König saß in pur pur und Hermelin gekleidet auf einem Thron, der schlicht aber majestätisch war.
Ein Unterthahn freute er sich, als er den kleinen Prinzen sah.
Und der kleine Prinz fragte, wie kommt es, dass sie mich kennen?
Sie haben mich noch nie zuvor gesehen.
Er wusste nicht, dass die Welt für Könige sehr einfach ist.
Alle Menschen sind Unterthahn.
Komm mal näher heran, damit ich dich besser sehen kann, sagte der König,
ganz stolz darauf, jemand des Königs einzukönnen.
Der kleine Prinz schaute sich nach einer Sitzgelegenheit um,
doch der herrliche Hermelin-Mantel nahm den ganzen Planeten ein.
So blieber stehen, doch Vermüdigkeit musste er gähnen.
Es gehört sich nicht, den Gegenwart eines Königs zu gähnen, ermahnte ihn der Munarch.
Ich untersage es dir.
Ich kann nichts dagegen machen, antwortete der kleine Prinz, ganz verwirrt.
Ich habe eine lange Reise hinter mir und kam nicht zum Schlafen.
Dann befehle ich dir zu gähnen, sagte der König zu ihm.
Seit Jahren habe ich niemand mehr gähnen gesehen.
Gähnen ist eine wahre Seltenheit für mich, also los, gähne nochmal.
Dies ist ein Befehl.
Das schüchtert mich ein.
Ich kann nicht mehr, erwiderte der Prinz und wurde ganz ruht.
Mh-hm, mh-hm, machte der König.
Dann befehle ich dir mal zu gähnen und mal zu...
Er stammelte ein wenig und schien verärgert,
denn dem König lag besonders daran, dass seine Autorität geschätzt würde.
Ungehorsam tolerierte er nicht.
Er war ein strenger Monarch.
Doch weil er sehr gültig war, gab er vernünftige Befehle.
Wenn ich den Befehl erteile, sagte er häufig,
dass sich ein General in einen Meeresvogel verwandeln soll
und der General gehorcht nicht.
So wäre es nicht sein Fehler, es wäre mein Fehler.
Darf ich mich setzen? fragte der kleine Prinz schüchter.
Ich befehle dir, dich zu setzen, antwortete der König
und rückte würdevoll einen Zipfel seines Hermelin-Mantels zurecht.
Aber der kleine Prinz wunderte sich.
Der Planet war winzig.
Über wen konnte der König denn regieren?
Oh-hoheit, sagte er, verzeiht mir, wenn ich sie unterbreche.
Ich befehle dir, mich zu unterbrechen,
sagte der König eilig.
Hoheit, worüber herrscht ihr?
Über alles, antwortete schlichtweg der König.
Über alles?
Mit einer taktvollen Geste zeigte der König auf seine Planeten,
auf die anderen Planeten und die Sterne.
Über das alles, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Über das alles, antwortete der König.
Denn er war nicht nur ein absoluter Monarch, sondern ein Universeller.
Und auch die Sterne gehorchen euch?
Natürlich, sagte der König.
Sie gehorchen aufs Wort.
Ich toleriere keinen Ungehorsam.
Der kleine Prinz bewunderte solch eine große Macht.
Wenn er sie selbst besäße, könnte er nicht nur 44,
sondern 72 oder gar 100 oder 200 Sonnenuntergänger
an einem Tag sehen, ohne nur ein einziges Mal seinen Stuhl zu verrücken.
Und weil er ein wenig traurig war beim Gedanken an seinen verlassenen Planeten,
fasste er Mut und bat den König um einen Gefallen.
Ich würde so gerne einen Sonnenuntergang sehen.
Macht mir die Freude, der fehlt der Sonne unterzugehen.
Wenn ich einem General den Befehl geben würde,
wie ein Schmetterling von einer Blume zur nächsten zu fliegen,
oder eine Tragödie zu verfassen,
oder sich in ein Meeresvogel zu verwandeln
und wenn der General den erhaltenen Befehl nicht ausführen würde,
wer von uns beiden wäre dann im Unrecht?
Er oder ich?
Er wäre das, antwortete der Prinz voller Überzeugung.
Genau. Man muss von jedem das verlangen, was er geben kann,
erwiderte der König.
Autorität erlangt man zu allererst durch Vernunft.
Befielst du einem Volk, sich ins Meer zu schmeißen?
So wird es eine Revolution anzetteln.
Ich habe das Recht, Gehäusern zu verlangen,
weil meine Befehle vernünftig sind.
Wie steht es also um meinen Sonnenuntergang?
fragte nochmals der kleine Prinz,
der niemals von einer Frage abließ,
wenn er sie einmal gestellt hatte.
Du bekommst deinen Sonnenuntergang,
ich werde ihn anordnen,
aber da ich zu regieren verstehe,
werde ich abwarten, bis die Umstände günstig sind.
Wann wird das sein?
wollte der kleine Prinz wissen.
Antwortete der König und schaute zunächst in einen dicken Kalender.
Es wird heute Abend um 7 Uhr 40 sein.
Und du wirst sehen, wie man mir geräucht.
Der kleine Prinz gähnt.
Er bedauerte, dass ihm der Sonnenuntergang vorenthalten blieb.
Und dann, lang wollte er sich schon ein bisschen.
Ich habe hier nichts mehr zu tun, sagte er zum König.
Ich werde wieder aufbrechen.
Geh nicht vor Ort! antwortete der König,
der so stolz darauf war, einen Untertan zu haben.
Geh nicht vor Ort! Ich, ich mache dich zum Minister.
So was war er Minister?
Zum, zum Justizminister.
Aber es gibt doch niemanden, den man verurteilen könnte.
Das weiß man doch nicht, sagte der König.
Ich war noch nicht an jedem Ort meines Königs Reiches.
Ich bin sehr alt und es fehlt der Platz für ein Gefährt.
Und das Laufen ermüdet mich.
Oh, aber ich habe es schon gesehen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Und neigte seinen Kopf, um nochmals auf die andere Seite des Planeten zu schauen.
Dort ist auch niemand.
So wirst du über dich selbst Urteil sprechen, sagte der König.
Das ist am schwierigsten, viel schwieriger, als über andere zu urteilen.
Wenn du es schaffst, über dich selbst ein Urteil zu fällen,
dann bist du ein wirklich weiser Mensch.
Ich, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Ich kann überall über mich selbst urteilen.
Dazu muss ich nicht hier wohnen.
Ähm, ähm, sagte der König.
Ich habe den Eindruck auf meinem Planeten, gibt es irgendwo eine alte Ratte.
Das Nachts höre ich sie.
Über diese alte Ratte könntest du ein Urteil fällen.
Von Zeit zu Zeit verurteilst du sie zum Tode.
Ihr Leben wird von deinem Urteil abhängen.
Aber jedes Mal wirst du sie begnadigen, denn sie muss ja aufgespart werden.
Es gibt schließlich nur eine.
Ich mag kein Todesurteil sprechen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Und ich werde jetzt lieber gehen.
Nein, sagte der König.
Zwar hatte der kleine Prinz schon alle Vorkehrungen betroffen,
aber er wollte den alten Monarchen nicht traurig machen.
Wenn eure Majestät sich wünscht, man möge zur rechten Zeit gehorchen,
so könnten sie mir einen vernünftigen Befehl geben.
Sie könnten zum Beispiel befehlen, ich solle innerhalb von einer Minute verschwinden.
Mir scheint, die Umstände sind günstig.
Weil der König nichts erwiderte, zögerte der kleine Prinz zunächst.
Aber dann brach er säufzend auf.
Ich mache dich zu meinem Botschafter, rief der König im eilig hinterher.
Er legte große Autorität an den Tag.
Die Erwachsenen sind doch wirklich sonderbar, sagte sich der kleine Prinz auf seiner Reise.
Kapitel 11.
Der zweite Planet wurde von einem Eitlern bewohnt.
Ah, ah, Besuch eines Verehrers.
Freute sich der Eitl, als er den kleinen Prinzen sah.
Denn für eitle Menschen sind alle anderen Verehrer.
Guten Tag, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Sie haben einen merkwürdigen Hut.
Der ist zum Größen, sagte der Eitl,
damit ich zurückgrüßen kann, wenn jemand mich anhimmelt.
Nur leider kommt hier nie jemand vorbei.
Ach so, sagte der kleine Prinz, ohne Recht zu verstehen.
Schlag mal mit der einen Hand auf die andere, red ihm der Eitl.
Der kleine Prinz schlug mit der einen auf die andere Hand.
Der Eitl grüßte in aller Bescheidenheit, indem er den Hut zog.
Das ist immerhin witziger als der Besuch beim König, sagte der kleine Prinz zu sich selbst.
Wieder schlug er die Hände zusammen.
Wieder zog der Eitl zum Gruß seinen Hut.
Nach fünf Minuten ödete die Eintönigkeit des Spiels den kleinen Prinzen an.
Und was muss man tun, damit der Hut runterfällt?
Doch der Eitl hörte ihn nicht.
Eitle Menschen hören nur, wenn sie gelobt werden.
Verehrst du mich wirklich? fragte er den kleinen Prinzen.
Was bedeutet verehren?
Verehren bedeutet zuzugeben, dass ich der schönste, am besten gekleidete,
reichste und intelligenteste Mensch auf dem Planeten bin.
Aber du bist ganz allein auf deinem Planeten.
Tu mir den Gefallen. Verehre mich trotzdem.
Ich verehre dich, sagte der kleine Prinz und zuckte dabei mit den Schultern.
Aber warum interessierte ich das bloß?
Und der kleine Prinz brach wieder auf.
Die Erwachsenen sind doch wirklich ungewöhnlich, sagte er sich auf seiner Reise.
Kapitel 12
Auf dem nächsten Planeten wohnte ein Säufer.
Es war ein sehr kurzer Besuch, doch tauchte er den kleinen Prinzen in eine große Traurigkeit.
Was machst du da? fragte er den Säufer, der schweigend vor einer Ansammlung leerer und voller Flaschen saß.
Ich saufe, antwortete Finster der Säufer.
Warum saß du? fragte ihn der kleine Prinz.
Um zu vergessen, sagte der Säufer.
Um was zu vergessen?
Erkundigte sich der kleine Prinz und bedauerte ihn schon.
Um zu vergessen, lös ich mich schäm.
Gab der Säufer zu und senkte den Kopf.
Für was schämst du dich? fragte der kleine Prinz, der den Wunsch hatte ihm zu helfen.
Für es saufen.
Gab der Säufer zu und vergrub sich endgültig in Schweigen.
Und ganz perplex machte sich der kleine Prinz wieder auf und davon.
Die Erwachsenen sind doch wirklich wunderlich, sagte er sich auf seiner Reise.
Kapitel 13
Der vierte Planet gehörte einem Geschäftsmann.
Der Mann war so beschäftigt, dass er bei der Ankunft des kleinen Prinzen nicht einmal den Kopf hob.
Guten Tag, sagte dieser zu ihm.
Ihre Zigarette ist ausgegangen.
3 und 2 macht 5, 5 und 7, 12, 12 und 3 ist 15.
15 und 7 ist 22. Keine Zeit, um sie wieder anzuziehen.
Das macht also 500, 1.622.731.
500 Millionen wovon?
Ne, du bist nur hier.
501 Millionen von, ich weiß es nicht mehr, ich habe so viel Arbeit.
Ich bin mit Ernst bei der Sache für Quatsch, habe ich keine Zeit.
2 und 5 ist 7.
500 Millionen wovon?
Wiederholte der kleine Prinz, den niemals von einer Frage abließ, wenn er sie einmal gestellt hatte.
Der Geschäftsmann hob den Kopf.
In den 54 Jahren, seit ich auf diesem Planeten lebe, wurde ich nur dreimal gestört.
Das erste Mal vor 22 Jahren, als ein Maikäfer von Weiss Gottwo herabgefallen ist.
Er machte einen furchtbaren Lärm.
Und ich habe mich beim Adiën gleich viermal verrechnet.
Das zweite Mal war vor 11 Jahren bei plötzlichen Gelenkschmerzen.
Ich mache zu wenig Sport.
Ich habe keine Zeit zu vertrötteln.
Ich bin mit Ernst bei der Sache.
Das dritte Mal, da haben wir es.
Ich war bei 501 Millionen, Millionen wovon?
Der Geschäftsmann verstand, dass er nicht darauf hoffen konnte, in Ruhe gelassen zu werden.
Millionen dieser kleinen Dinger, die man manchmal am Himmel sieht, fliegen?
Aber nein, diese kleinen leuchtenden Dinger.
Bienen?
Aber nein, kleine goldene Dinger, die Faulpälzer zum Träumen bringen.
Aber ich bin mit Ernst bei der Sache.
Ich habe keine Zeit zum Träumen.
Ah, die Sterne.
Ja, genau, so ist es die Sterne.
Und was machst du mit 500 Millionen Sternen?
501 Millionen, 622.733.
Ich bin mit Ernst bei der Sache.
Ich bin exakt.
Und was machst du mit diesen Sternen?
Was ich damit mache?
Ja.
Nichts, ich besitze sie.
Du besitzt die Sterne?
Ja.
Aber ich habe schon einen König getroffen, der Könige besitze nichts.
Sie regieren über.
Das ist etwas anderes.
Und was bringt es dir, Sterne zu besitzen?
Dadurch bin ich reich.
Und was bringt es dir, reich zu sein?
So kann ich andere Sterne kaufen, wenn jemand welche findet.
Dieser Typ, sagte sich der kleine Prinz.
Er denkt ein bisschen so wie mein Säufer.
Dennoch stellt er weitere Fragen.
Wie kann man den Sterne besitzen?
Wem gehören sie denn?
Gab der Geschäftsmann Mürisch zurück.
Ich weiß nicht.
Niemandem?
Na, dann gehören sie mir.
Denn ich habe als Erster daran gedacht.
Das reicht aus?
Sicher.
Wenn du einen Diamanten findest, der niemandem gehört, so gehört er dir.
Wenn du eine Insel findest, die niemandem gehört, so gehört sie dir.
Wenn du als Erster eine Idee hast, lässt du sie patentieren.
Sie gehört dir.
Und mir gehören die Sterne.
Denn niemand vor mir hat sich darum geschärt, sie zu besetzen.
Das stimmt wohl, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Und was machst du mit ihnen?
Ich verwalte sie.
Ich zähle sie.
Und dann zähle ich sie wieder, sagte der Geschäftsmann.
Das ist schwierig, aber ich bin ein ernstzunehmender Mann.
Der kleine Prinz war nicht zufrieden.
Ich besetze einen Schal, den kann ich mir um den Hals benden und mitnehmen.
Wenn mir eine Blume gehört, kann ich sie pflücken und mitnehmen.
Aber du kannst die Sterne ja nicht pflücken.
Nein, aber ich kann sie auf die Bank bringen.
Was soll das heißen?
Das bedeutet, ich schreibe die Anzahl der Sterne auf ein klein Zettel.
Und diesen Zettel verschließe ich dann in einer Schublade.
Das ist alles?
Ja, das war ich schon.
Das ist witzig, dachte der kleine Prinz.
Das klingt fast poetisch, aber wirklich ernst gemeint ist es nicht.
Von ernsten Dingen hatte der kleine Prinz eine ganz andere Vorstellung, als die Erwachsenen.
Ich, sagte er noch, ich besetze eine Blume, die ich jeden Tag gieße.
Ich besetze drei Vulkanen, die ich jede Woche fege.
Ich fege sogar jenen, der schon erloschen ist.
Man weiß ja nie.
Mein Vulkan nutzt es ebenso wie meine Blume, dass ich sie besetze.
Aber für deine Sterne bist du ganz unnütz.
Der Geschäftsmann öffnete den Mund, aber ihm fiel keine Antwort ein.
Und der kleine Prinz machte sich auf und davon.
Die Erwachsenen sind doch wirklich komisch, sagte er sich auf seiner Reise.
Kapitel 14.
Der fünfte Planet war äußerst merkwürdig.
Es war der kleinste von allen.
Es gab gerade genug Platz für eine Straßenlaterne und einen Laternanzünder.
Der kleine Prinz konnte sich nicht erklären, wozu man irgendwo im Himmel,
auf einem Planeten ohne Häuser und Menschen, eine Straßenlaterne
und einen Laternanzünder gebrauchen könnte.
Dennoch sagte er sich, gut möglich, dass dieser Mann merkwürdig ist.
Dennoch ist er nicht so merkwürdig wie der König, der Eitle, der Geschäftsmann oder der Säufer.
Seine Arbeit hat zumindest einen Sinn.
Wenn er seine Laterne anzündet, dann ist es so, als würde er einen neuen Stern erschaffen.
Oder eine Blume.
Wenn er seine Laterne löscht, schläft ein Stern ein.
Das ist eine sehr schöne Beschäftigung.
Es ist wirklich nützlich, alles schön ist.
Als er auf dem Planeten landete, grüßte er den Laternanzünder respektvoll.
Guten Tag.
Warum hast du denn gerade deine Laterne gelöscht?
So lautet die Vorschrift.
Sagt der Laternanzünder.
Guten Tag.
Was ist die Vorschrift?
Die Laterne zu löschen.
Guten Abend.
Und er zündete sie wieder an.
Warum hast du sie nun wieder angezündet?
Das ist die Vorschrift.
antwortete der Laternanzünder.
Ich verstehe es nicht, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Da gibt es nichts zu verstehen.
Sagt der Laternanzünder.
Vorschrift ist Vorschrift.
Guten Tag.
Und er machte die Laterne aus.
Dann wischte er sich mit einem rotkarierten Taschentuch die Stern ab.
Ich habe einen schrecklichen Beruf.
Früher war das vernünftig.
Am Morgen löschte ich sie aus.
Und am Abend zündete ich sie wieder an.
Der Rest des Tages blieb mir zum Erholen und die Nacht zum Schlafen.
Und seitdem wurde die Vorschrift geändert?
Die Vorschrift hat sich nicht geändert, sagte der Laternanzünder.
Das ist ja das Drama.
Der Planet hat sich von Jahr zu Jahr schneller gedreht,
aber die Vorschrift wurde nicht geändert.
Und? sagte der kleine Prinz.
Jetzt dreht er sich einmal pro Minute.
Mir bleibt keine Sekunde Pause.
Pro Minute zünder ich einmal an und lösche einmal aus.
Das ist lustig.
Bei dir dauern die Tage nur eine Minute.
Das ist überhaupt nicht lustig, sagte der Laternanzünder.
Jetzt drehten wir schon einen Monat lang miteinander.
Ein Monat? Ja, 30 Minuten, 30 Tage.
Und er zündete seine Laterne wieder an.
Der kleine Prinz schaute ihn an.
Und er liebte diesen Anzünder, der sich so streng an die Vorschrift hielt.
Er erinnerte sich an die Sonnenuntergänge
und wie er auf deren Suche früher seinen Stuhl rückte.
Er wollte seinem Freund helfen.
Weißt du, ich weiß einen Weg, wie du dich ausruhen kannst,
wann immer du möchtest.
Immer her damit, sagte der Laternanzünder.
Man kann gleichzeitig pflichtbewusst und faul sein.
Der kleine Prinz fuhr fort.
Dein Planet ist derart klein,
dass du ihn mit drei Hüpfern umrundet hast.
Du musst nur sehr langsam laufen, um immer in der Sonne zu bleiben.
Wenn du dich ausruhen willst, läufst du.
Und der Tag dauert so lange, wie du machst.
Das bringt mich nicht sonderlich weiter, sagte der Anzünder.
Was ich im Leben liebe, ist das Schlafen.
Dann bringt es nichts.
Dann bringt es wohl nichts, sagte der Anzünder.
Guten Tag.
Und er löschte seine Laterne.
Dieser Kerl, sagte sich der kleine Prinz,
während er seiner Reise fortsetzte.
Dieser Kerl würde von allen anderen verachtet werden.
Von König, vom Eitlern, vom Seufer und vom Geschäftsmann.
Dennoch ist er der Einzige, den mir nicht lächerlich vorkommt.
Vielleicht, weil er sich nicht nur mit sich selbst beschäftigt,
er säufzte vor Bedauern und sagte sich noch,
dieser Kerl ist der Einzige, mit dem ich mich angefreundet hätte.
Aber sein Planet ist wirklich zu klein.
Es gibt keinen Platz für zwei.
Was sich der kleine Prinz nicht einzugestehen wagte war,
dass er diesem Planeten vor allem wegen der 1.440 Sonnenuntergänge
in 24 Stunden nachdrauert.
8.15.
Der sechste Planet war um das zehnfache Größer.
Hier wohnte ein alter Herr, der dicke Bücher schrieb.
Seh da, ein Forscher, freute er sich,
als er den kleinen Prinzen erblickte.
Der kleine Prinz setzte sich an den Tisch,
um ein wenig zu verschnaufen.
Er war schon so viel herumgereist.
Wo kommst du her? fragte ihn der Alter her.
Was ist das für ein dickes Buch? sagte der kleine Prinz.
Was treiben sie her?
Ich bin Geograph, sagte der Alter.
Was ist ein Geograph?
Das ist ein Wissenschaftler, der weiß,
wo sich die Meere befinden, die Flüsse,
die Städte, die Berge und die Füßen.
Das ist sehr interessant, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Das ist endlich mal ein richtiger Beruf.
Er schaute sich den Planeten des Geographen an.
Er hatte noch niemals einen so herrschaftlichen Planeten gesehen.
Er ist so wunderschön, euer Planet.
Gibt es Meere?
Das kann ich nicht wissen, sagte der Geograph.
Ah, der kleine Prinz war schon enttäuscht.
Und Berge?
Das kann ich nicht wissen, sagte der Geograph.
Und Städte und Flüsse und Wüsten?
Auch das kann ich nicht wissen, sagte der Geograph.
Aber sie sind doch Geograph.
Das stimmt wohl, sagte der Geograph.
Aber ich bin kein Forscher.
Mir fehlt es an Forschergeist.
Nicht der Geograph wird die Städte, Flüsse, Berge,
Meere, Ozeane und Wüsten zählen.
Der Geograph ist zu bedeutend, um sich herumzutreiben.
Er verlässt sein Schreibtisch nicht.
Aber er empfängt die Forscher.
Er befragt sie.
Er notiert ihre Erinnerungen.
Und wenn die Erinnerungen ihm interessant erscheinen,
veranlasst der Geograph eine Untersuchung
über die Glaubwürdigkeit des Forschers.
Wozu denn?
Weil ein Forscher der Lügen verbreitet,
an Katastrophen in unseren Geografiebüchern schuld wäre.
Und auch ein Forscher, der zu viel säuft.
Wie das, fragte der kleine Prinz.
Weil bedrunkene Doppelzehen.
So würde der Geograph zwei Berge verzeichnen,
wo es nur einen einzigen gibt.
Ich kenne da jemanden, sagte der kleine Prinz,
der ein schlechter Forscher wäre.
Das ist wohl möglich.
Wenn der Forscher also glaubwürdig erscheint,
dann macht man eine Untersuchung über seine Entdeckung.
Schaut man nach?
Nein, das ist so kompliziert.
Aber man verlangt von dem Forscher, dass er Beweise liefert.
Handelt es sich beispielsweise um die Entdeckung eines großen Berges.
So verlangt man von ihm Steine von dort mitzubringen.
Plötzlich war der Geograph ganz aufgeregt.
Aber du, du kommst doch von weit her.
Du bist ein Forscher.
Du wirst mir deinen Planeten beschreiben.
Und der Geograph hatte schon sein Verzeichnis aufgeschlagen
und spitzte seinen Bleistift.
Zuerst notiert man die Berichte der Forscher mit dem Bleistift.
Mit der Tinte wartet man so lange,
bis der Forscher die Beweise geliefert hat.
Also fragte der Geograph.
Oh, bei mir, sagte der kleine Prinz,
ist es nicht sonderlich interessant.
Es ist winzig.
Ich habe drei Vulkanen.
Zwei sind aktiv und einer ist erloschen.
Aber man weiß ja nie.
Man weiß nie, sagte der Geograph.
Eine Blume habe ich auch.
Wir schreiben hier keine Blumen auf, sagte der Geograph.
Wieso?
Das ist doch das Schönste.
Weil Blumen vergänglich sind.
Was heißt vergänglich?
Geografiebücher sind von allen Büchern die wertvollsten.
Sie sind nie überholt.
Es ist sehr selten, dass ein Berg seinen Platz ändert.
Es ist selten, dass sich ein Ozean lehrt.
Wir schreiben ewige Dinge auf.
Aber erloschende Vulkanen können wieder ausbrechen.
Unterbrach ihn der kleine Prinz.
Was bedeutet vergänglich?
Ob Vulkanen nun erloschen sind oder wieder ausbrechen,
läuft für uns auf das Leiche hinaus, sagte der Geograph.
Was für uns zählt, ist der Berg.
Er verändert sich nicht.
Aber was heißt vergänglich?
Wiederholte der kleine Prinz,
der niemals von einer Frage ables, die er einmal gestellt hatte.
Das bedeutet, dass etwas von baldigem Verschwinden bedroht ist.
Meine Blume ist von baldigem Verschwinden bedroht?
Natürlich.
Meine Blume ist vergänglich, sagte sich der kleine Prinz.
Und sie hat nur vier Downen, um sich gegen die Welt zu verteidigen.
Und ich hab sie ganz allein bei mir zurückgelassen.
Da spürte er das erste Mal Bedauern.
Aber er fasste neuen Mut.
Was empfehlen sie mir für einen Besuch? fragte er.
Der Planeten Erde, antwortete der Geograph.
Er hat einen guten Ruf.
Da machte sich der kleine Prinz auf den Weg
und war in Gedanken bei seiner Blume.
Kapitel 16.
Die siebente Planet war die Erde.
Die Erde ist nicht irgendein Planet.
Man zählt dort 111 Könige.
Natürlich nicht ohne die Farbigen mit zu zählen.
7000 Geografen, 900.000 Geschäftsmänner, 7,5 Millionen Seufer,
311 Millionen Eitle.
Das heißt, ungefähr 2 Milliarden Erwachsene.
Um euch eine Idee von den Ausmaßen der Erde zu geben,
würde ich sagen, dass man vor der Erfindung der Elektrizität
auf allen sechs Kontinenten eine Armee aus 462.511 Laternen
an Zündern beschäftigen musste.
Aus der Ferne sah das umwerfend aus.
Die Bewegungen dieser Armee waren einstudiert
wie bei einer Ballettgruppe an der Oper.
Zuerst waren die Anzünder in Neuseeland und Australien an der Reihe.
Die gingen schlafen, wenn ihre Laternen angezündet waren.
Dann begann der Tanz der Laternen-Anzünder in China und Zibirien.
Dann verschwanden auch sie hinter den Kulissen.
So waren die Anzünder in Russland und Indien an der Reihe.
Dann die in Afrika und Europa.
Dann die in Südamerika.
Schließlich jene in Nordamerika.
Niemals verwechselten sie die Reihenfolge ihres Auftritts.
Es war großartig.
Nur der Anzünder der einzigen Laterne am Nordpol
und sein Kollege mit der einzigen Laterne am Südpol
führten ein untätiges und gemächtliches Leben.
Sie arbeiteten nur zweimal im Jahr.
Kapitel 17.
Wenn man klug wirken will, passiert es,
wenn man ein wenig schwindelt.
Ich war nicht ganz ehrlich,
als ich euch von den Laternen-Anzündern erzählte.
Es könnte ein volles Bild von unserem Planeten entstehen,
bei jenen, die ihn nicht kennen.
Die Menschen nehmen nur wenig Platz auf der Erde ein.
Wenn die 2 Milliarden Einwohner, die auf der Erde leben,
sich wie für eine Versammlung eng nebeneinander stellen würden,
dann genügte für sie ein öffentlicher Platz von 20 Meilen Länge
und 20 Meilen Breite.
Man könnte die gesamte Menschheit
auf der kleinsten pazifischen Insel unterkriegen.
Die Erwachsenen werden euch das natürlich nicht abnehmen.
Sie glauben, sie nehmen sehr viel Platz ein.
Sie finden sie sein ebenso imposant wie Offenbrotbäume.
Ihr solltet ihnen raten, das mal zu berechnen.
Sie lieben Zahlen, das wird ihnen gefallen.
Aber verliert nicht eure Zeit damit.
Das ist unnütz. Ihr vertraut mir her.
Auf der Erde angekommen war der kleine Prinz erstaunt,
niemanden zu sehen.
Er hatte schon Angst, sich im Planeten geirrt zu haben,
als sich ein mondfarbener Kringel in der Erde bewegte.
Gute Nacht, sagte der Prinz, auf gut Glück.
Gute Nacht, antwortete die Schlange.
Auf welchem Planeten bin ich gelandet? fragte der kleine Prinz.
Auf der Erde, in Afrika, antwortete die Schlange.
Ah, gibt es denn niemanden auf der Erde?
Hier ist die Wüste. Es gibt niemanden in der Wüste.
Die Erde ist groß, sagte die Schlange.
Der kleine Prinz setzte sich auf einen Stein und schaute hinauf in den Himmel.
Ich frage mich, sagte er, ob die Sterne erleuchtet sind,
damit jeder eines Tages seinen Stern wiederfinden kann.
Schau dir meinen Planeten an.
Er ist gerade genau über uns.
Aber wie weit er doch fort ist?
Er ist schön, sagte die Schlange.
Das machst du hier.
Ich habe Schwierigkeiten mit deiner Blume, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Ah, sagte die Schlange.
Und sie schwiegen.
Wo sind die Menschen? fuhr der kleine Prinz fort.
Man ist ganz einsam in der Wüste.
Bei den Menschen ist man auch einsam, sagte die Schlange.
Der kleine Prinz schaute sie lange an.
Du bist ein lustiges Tier, sagte er schließlich.
So dünn wie ein Finger.
Aber ich bin mein...
sagte die Schlange.
Der kleine Prinz lächelte.
Du bist auch nicht stark.
Du hast nicht einmal Füße.
Du kannst nicht mal herumkommen, sagte die Schlange.
Sie rollte sich um den Knöchel des kleinen Prinzen wie ein Goldarmband.
Der kleine Prinz antwortete nichts.
Kleid mit dir, so schwach wie du bist auf dieser Erde gesehen sucht nach deinem Planeten.
Oh, ich habe sehr gut verstanden, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Aber warum sprichst du immer in Rätseln?
Ich löse sie alle, sagte die Schlange.
Und sie schwiegen.
Kapitel 18.
Der kleine Prinz lief durch die Wüste und begegnete nur einer Blume.
Einer Blume mit drei Blütenblättern, einer ganz mikrigen Blume.
Guten Tag, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Guten Tag, sagte die Blume.
Wo sind die Menschen?
fragte der Prinz höflich.
Die Blume hatte eines Tages eine Karawane vorbeifahren sehen.
Die Menschen?
Ich glaube es gibt sechs oder sieben.
Ich habe sie gesehen, nur ist das Jahre her.
Man weiß ja nie wo man sie findet.
Der Wind treibt sie umher.
Ihnen fehlen Wurzeln, das macht ihnen zu schaffen.
Adieu, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Adieu, sagte die Blume.
Kapitel 19.
Der kleine Prinz bestieg einen hohen Berg.
Die einzigen Berge die Erkante waren die drei Vulkanen, die ihm bis zu den Knien reichten.
Und den erloschenen Vulkan benutzte er als Hocker.
Von einem so hohen Berg, sagte er sich, werde ich den ganzen Planeten und alle Menschen auf einmal sehen.
Aber er sah nur die Spitzen von scharfen Felsen.
Guten Tag, sagte er auf gut Glück.
Guten Tag, guten Tag, guten Tag.
antwortete das Echo.
Wer seid ihr? sagte der kleine Prinz.
Wer seid ihr? Wer seid ihr? Wer seid ihr? antwortete das Echo.
Werdet meine Freunde? Ich bin allein, sagte er.
Ich bin allein, ich bin allein, ich bin allein. antwortete das Echo.
Was für ein komischer Planet, dachte er.
Er ist ganz trocken, alles ist spitz und salzig.
Und die Menschen haben keine Fantasie.
Sie wiederholen, was man ihnen sagt.
Bei mir zu Hause hatte ich eine Blume.
Die sprach immer als Erster.
Kapitel 20.
Aber als der kleine Prinz lange über Sand, Felsen und durch Schnee gewandert war,
geschah es, dass er endlich eine Straße entdeckte.
Und alle Straßen führen zu Menschen.
Guten Tag, sagte er.
Es war ein Garten voll blühender Rosen.
Guten Tag, sagte die Rosen.
Der kleine Prinz schaute sie an.
Sie gelichen alle seiner Blume.
Wer seid ihr? fragte er sie verdutzt.
Wer sind Rosen?
sagten die Rosen.
Ah, machte der kleine Prinz.
Und er fühlte sich sehr unglücklich.
Seine Blume hatte ihm erzählt, sie sei im ganzen Universum die einzige ihrer Art.
Und hier gab es gleich 5.000 von ihnen, die alle gleich aussahen, in einem einzigen Garten.
Sie wäre sicher beleidigt, sagte er sich, wenn sie das sehen würde.
Sie würde schrecklich husten und vorgeben, zu sterben, um sich nicht lächerlich zu machen.
Und ich wäre wohl gezwungen so zu tun, als ob ich sie pflegte.
Denn ansonsten gäbe sie sich wirklich dem Sterben hin, um auch mich zu verletzen.
Dann sagte er sich noch, ich dachte, ich sei reich, dank meiner einzigartigen Blume.
Und dabei besitze ich nur eine gewöhnliche Rose.
Dazu meine drei Vulkanen, die mir bis an die Knie reichen.
Und von denen einer vielleicht für immer erloschen ist.
Das macht keinen sonderlich großen Prinzen aus mir.
Und er legte sich ins Gas und weinte.
Kapitel 21.
In diesem Moment tauchte der Fuchs auf.
Gottentag, sagte der Fuchs,
Gottentag antwortete der kleine Prinz höflich.
Er drehte sich um, aber sah nichts.
Hier bin ich, sagte die Stimme, unter dem Apfelbaum.
Wer bist du, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Du bist sehr hübsch.
Ich bin ein Fuchs, sagte der Fuchs.
Komm, spiel mit mir, schlug der kleine Prinz vor.
Ich bin so traurig.
Ich kann nicht mit dir spielen, sagte der Fuchs.
Ich bin nicht gezähmt.
Ah, verzeihung, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Er überlegte und fügte an.
Was bedeutet zähmen?
Du bist nicht von hier, sagte der Fuchs.
Was suchst du?
Ich suche die Menschen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Was bedeutet zähmen?
Die Menschen, sagte der Fuchs.
Sie haben Gewehre und sie jagen.
Das ist ungeheuerlästig.
Sie züchten auch Hühner.
Nur das interessiert sie.
Suchst du Hühner?
Nein, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Ich suche Freunde.
Was bedeutet zähmen?
Das ist eine fast vergessen Sache, sagte der Fuchs.
Es bedeutet sich vertraut machen.
Vertraut machen?
Natürlich, sagte der Fuchs.
Für mich bist du nur ein kleiner Junge, der aussieht wie tausend andere kleine Junge.
Und ich brauche dich nicht.
Und du brauchst mich auch nicht.
Ich bin für dich nur ein Fuchs, der aussieht wie hunderttausend andere Füchse.
Aber wenn du mich zähmst, brauchen wir einander.
Du wirst für mich auf der ganzen Welt einmalig sein.
Ich werde für dich auf der ganzen Welt einmalig sein.
Ich fange an zu begreifen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Es gibt eine Blume.
Ich glaube, sie hat mich gezähmt.
Das ist möglich, sagte der Fuchs.
Auf der Erde sieht man alle möglichen Dinge.
Oh, das ist nicht auf der Erde, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Der Fuchs schien sehr verdutzt.
Auf einem anderen Planeten?
Ja.
Gibt es Jäger auf diesem Planeten?
Nein.
Das ist interessant.
Und Hühner?
Nein.
Nichts ist perfekt, so öffnste der Fuchs.
Aber der Fuchs fing wieder von seiner Idee an.
Mein Leben ist eintönig.
Ich hage Hühner.
Die Menschen jagen mich.
Alle Hühner ähneln sich und alle Menschen ähneln sich.
Ich langweile mich ein wenig.
Aber wenn du mich zähmst, wird mein Leben mit Heitakkeit erfüllt sein.
Ich werde den Klang deines Schrittes kennen,
der sich von allen anderen unterscheidet.
Die anderen Schritte werden mich unter die Erde jagen.
Dein Schritt wird mich aus dem Bau locken, wie Musik.
Und schau, siehst du die Weizenfelder dort?
Ich esse kein Brut.
Weizen ist für mich unnütz.
Weizenfelder erinnern mich an Rhein gar nichts.
Und das ist traurig.
Aber du hast goldene Haare.
Wundervoll wird das sein, wenn du mich ähneln.
Wundervoll wird das sein, wenn du mich erst gezähmt hast.
Der goldene Weizen wird mich an dich erinnern.
Und ich werde es lieben.
Das Rauschen des Windes im Getreide.
Der Fuchs schwieg und schaute den kleinen Prinzen lange an.
Bitte zähme mich, sagte er.
Das möchte ich gern, antwortete der kleine Prinz.
Aber ich habe nicht viel Zeit.
Ich muss Freunde finden und viele Dinge kennenlernen.
Man kennt nur die Dinge, die man zähmt, sagte der Fuchs.
Die Menschen haben keine Zeit mehr, um etwas kennenzulernen.
Sie kaufen die schon fertigen Dinge im Laden.
Aber weil es keine Läden für Freunde gibt, haben die Menschen keine Freunde mehr.
Wenn du einen Freund willst, dann zähme mich.
Was muss ich tun? sagte der kleine Prinz.
Man muss Geduld haben, antwortete der Fuchs.
Zuerst setzt du dich ein Stück weit entfernt von mir ins Gras.
Ich werde dich aus dem Augenwinkel anschauen und du wirst nichts sagen.
Die Sprache sorgt für Missverständnisse.
Aber jeden Tag wirst du ein bisschen näher rücken können.
Am nächsten Morgen kehrte der Prinz zurück.
Es wäre besser gewesen, du wirst um die gleiche Zeit zurückgekommen, sagte der Fuchs.
Wenn du zum Beispiel um vier Uhr Nachmittags kommst, werde ich ab drei Uhr damit beginnen, glücklich zu sein.
Umso später es ist, umso glücklicher werde ich mich fühlen.
Um vier Uhr bereits werde ich aufgeregt sein und mir Sorgen machen.
Ich werde den Preis des Glöckens entdecken.
Kommst du aber immer irgendwann, werde ich nie wissen, wann ich mein Herz bereit halten soll.
Es muss feste Bräuche geben.
Was ist dein Brauch? sagte der kleine Prinz.
Auch das wird viel zu oft vergessen, sagte der Fuchs.
Es sorgt dafür, dass ein Tag anders ist als die anderen, eine Stunde anders als die anderen stunden.
Bei meinen Jägern zum Beispiel gibt es einen Brauch.
Donnerstags tanzen sie mit den Mädchen aus dem Dorf.
Also ist Donnerstag ein wundervoller Tag.
Ich spaziere bis zum Weinberg hinauf.
Wenn die Jäger irgendwann einmal tanzen würden, sehen die Tage alle gleich aus.
Und ich hätte niemals Ferien.
So zähmte der kleine Prinz den Fuchs.
Und als die Stunde des Abschiedsnate.
Ach, sagte der Fuchs.
Ich werde weinen.
Das ist deine Schuld, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Ich wünschte dir keineswegs etwas Schlechtes, aber du wolltest, dass ich dich zähme.
Natürlich, sagte der Fuchs.
Aber du wirst weinen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Also hast du nichts gewonnen?
Ich habe etwas gewonnen.
Sagt der Fuchs.
Wegen der Farbe des Walzens.
Dann fügte er hinzu.
Schau dir noch mal die Rosen an.
Du wirst begreifen, dass deine einmalig auf der Welt ist.
Du wirst wiederkommen, um mir Adieu zu sagen.
Und ich werde dir ein Geheimnis schenken.
Der kleine Prinz ging sich noch einmal die Rosen ansehen.
Ihr seht, meiner Rose überhaupt nicht ähnlich.
Ihr taugt rein gar nichts, sagte er ihnen.
Niemand hat euch gezähmt und ihr habt niemanden gezähmt.
Ihr seid wie mein Fuchs.
Er war nur ein Fuchs wie hunderttausend andere.
Aber ich habe aus ihm meinen Freund gemacht.
Und nun ist er einmalig auf der ganzen Welt.
Und die Rosen waren sehr verlegen.
Ihr seid schön, aber ihr seid leer, sagte er ihnen noch.
Man kann für euch nicht sterben.
Natürlich könnte irgendwer im Vorbeilaufen glauben,
dass meine Rose euch ähnlich seht.
Aber sie selbst kann sich viel wichtiger nehmen, als ihr alle.
Weil sie es ist, die ich gegossen habe.
Weil sie es ist, die ich unter die Glasglocke gestellt habe.
Weil sie es ist, die ich mit dem Wandschirm geschützt habe.
Weil sie es ist, deren Raub mich aufgelesen habe.
Bis auf die zwei oder drei der Schmetterlinge wehten.
Weil sie es ist, die ich klagen hörte.
Oder brahlen.
Oder manchmal sogar schweigen, weil es meine Rose ist.
Und er wandte sich erneut an den Fuchs.
Adieu, sagte er.
Adieu, sagte der Fuchs.
Hier ist mein Geheimnis.
Es ist sehr einfach.
Man sieht nur mit dem Herzen.
Das Wesentliche ist für die Augen unsichtbar.
Wiederholte der kleine Prinz, um sich daran zu erinnern.
Es ist die Zeit, die du für deine Rose geopfert hast, die sie so bedeutsam macht.
Es ist die Zeit, die ich für meine Rose geopfert habe,
die sie so bedeutsam macht.
Sagt er der kleine Prinz, um sich daran zu erinnern.
Die Menschen haben diese Wahrheit vergessen, sagte der Fuchs.
Aber du sollst sie nicht vergessen.
Du wirst immer verantwortlich sein für das, was du zähmst.
Du bist verantwortlich für deine Rose.
Ich bin verantwortlich für meine Rose.
Wiederholte der kleine Prinz, um sich daran zu erinnern.
Kapitel 22.
Guten Tag, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Guten Tag, sagte der Weichensteller.
Was machst du hier, sagte der kleine Prinz?
Ich gruppiere die Reisenden in Tausender Box, sagte der Weichensteller.
Ich schicke die Züge, mit denen sie reisen, mal nach rechts, mal nach links.
Und ein erleuchteter Schnellzug, der wie Donner grollte,
ließ das Häuschen des Weichenstellers erzittern.
Sie haben es aber eilig, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Wohin wollen sie?
Der Zugführer weiß es selbst nicht, sagte der Weichensteller.
Und ein erleuchteter Schnellzug donnerte in die entgegengesetzte Richtung vorbei.
Sie kommen schon zurück, fragte der kleine Prinz.
Das sind nicht die selben, sagte der Weichensteller.
Sie wurden ausgetauscht.
Waren sie nicht zufrieden dort, wo sie waren?
Man ist niemals dort zufrieden, wo man ist, sagte der Weichensteller.
Und der Donner eines dritten Schnellzugs grollte.
Verfolgen sie die ersten Reisenden? fragte der kleine Prinz.
Sie verfolgen gar nichts, sagte der Weichensteller.
Sie schlafen im Inneren oder sie gähnen,
nur die Kinder drücken ihre Nasen an den Scheibenblatt.
Nur die Kinder wissen wohin sie wollen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Sie wenden ihre Zeit an eine Stoffpuppe und sie wächst ihnen so ans Herz.
Und nimmt man sie ihnen weg, dann weinen sie.
Sie haben es gut, sagte der Weichensteller.
Kapitel 23.
Guten Tag, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Guten Tag, sagte der Händler.
Er handelte mit Durststillen den Spezialpillen.
Man schluckt eine pro Woche und schon hat man nicht mehr das Bedürfnis zu trinken.
Warum verkaufst du das? sagte der kleine Prinz.
Das spart viel Zeit, sagte der Händler.
Experten haben das schon berechnet.
Man spart 53 Minuten pro Woche.
Und was macht man mit den 53 Minuten?
Man macht damit, was man will.
Ich, sagte sich der kleine Prinz.
Ich würde, wenn ich 53 Minuten übrig hätte,
kann es in Ruhe zu einem Brunnen laufen.
Kapitel 24.
Nun war meine Panne in der Wüste schon acht Tage her.
Und ich hatte mir gerade die Geschichte vom Pillenhändler angehört,
als ich den letzten Tropfen meines Wasservorrates trank.
Ach, sagte ich zum kleinen Prinzen.
Sie sind sehr schön, deine Erinnerungen.
Aber ich habe mein Flugzeug noch nicht repariert.
Ich habe nichts mehr zu trinken und ich wäre glücklich,
wenn auch ich ganz in Ruhe zu einem Brunnen laufen könnte.
Mein Freund, der Fuchs, sagte er.
Mein kleines Kerlchen, es geht nicht mehr um den Fuchs.
Warum?
Weil wir verdursten werden.
Er verstand meine Erklärung nicht und antwortete.
Es ist gut, einen Freund gehabt zu haben, selbst wenn man sterben muss.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich einen Fuchs zum Freund hatte.
Er erkennt die Gefahr nicht, sagte ich mir.
Er hat niemals Hunger oder Durst.
Ihm reicht ein bisschen Sonne.
Aber er sah mich an und antwortete auf meine Gedanken.
Ich habe auch Durst.
Zocken wir einen Brunnen.
Ich machte eine verzweifelte Geste.
Es ist absurd, auf gut Glück einen Brunnen in der Unendlichkeit der Wüste zu suchen.
Dennoch machten wir uns auf den Weg.
Als wir stundenlang schweigend herumgelaufen waren, brach die Nacht herein,
und die Sterne begannen zu leuchten.
Ich nahm sie wahr wie im Traum.
Ich hatte ein bisschen Fieber, das machte der Durst.
Die Worte des kleinen Prinzen tanzten durch mein Bewusstsein.
Du hast also auch Durst?
fragte ich ihn.
Aber er antwortete nicht auf meine Frage.
Er sagte nur, dass er ist auch gut für das Herz.
Ich verstand seine Antwort nicht und ich schwieg.
Ich wusste ja, dass man ihn nicht ausfragen sollte.
Er war müde.
Er setzte sich hin.
Ich setzte mich neben ihn.
Und nach einem Augenblick stille, sagte er noch,
die Sterne sind schön,
weil sie an eine Blume erinnern, die man nicht sieht.
Ich antwortete, das stimmt.
Und ich schaute schweigend auf die Falten im Sand unter dem Mond.
Die Wüste ist schön, fügte er hinzu.
Und das stimmte.
Ich habe die Wüste immer geliebt.
Man setzt sich auf eine Sanddühne.
Man sieht nichts.
Man hört nichts.
Und trotzdem leuchtet etwas im Stillen.
Was die Wüste so schön macht, sagte der kleine Prinz,
ist, dass sie irgendwo ein Bonn versteckt hält.
Ich war überrascht, plötzlich dieses rätselhafte Leuchten des Sandes zu verstehen.
Als ich ein kleiner Junge war, wohnte ich in einem alten Haus.
Und der Legende nach war dort ein Schatz versteckt.
Natürlich gelang es nie, jemandem ihn zu entdecken.
Vielleicht nicht mal danach zu suchen.
Aber er verzauberte das ganze Haus.
Mein Haus versteckte am Grunde seines Herzens ein Geheimnis.
Herr, sagte ich zum kleinen Prinzen,
ob es sich nun um das Haus, die Sterne oder die Wüste handelt.
Was ihre Schönheit ausmacht, ist unsichtbar.
Ich bin zufrieden, sagte er,
dass du es genauso siehst wie mein Fuchs.
Weil der kleine Prinz einschlief, nahm ich ihn in meiner Arme und lief weiter.
Ich war gerührt.
Mir schien ich trüger einen zerbrechlichen Schatz.
Es schien mir sogar so, als gäbe es nichts zerbrechlicheres auf der Erde.
Ich schaute im Mondlicht auf diese blasse Stirn, die geschlossenen Augen,
die Haarstreinen, die im Wind zitterten.
Und ich sagte mir, was ich vor mir sehe, ist nur eine Hülle.
Das eigentliche ist unsichtbar.
Da seine halb geöffneten Lippen ein halbes Lächeln andeuteten,
sagte ich mir noch,
dass mich am kleinen schlafenden Prinzen so rührt,
ist seine Treue zu einer Blume.
Das ist das Bild einer Rose, das in ihm strahlt,
wie die Flamme einer Kerze.
Selbst wenn er schläft.
Und er erschien mir noch zerbrechlicher.
Man muss Kerzen gut schützen.
Schon ein Windstoß kann sie auslöschen.
Und während ich so lief, entdeckte ich bei Tagesanbruch den Brunnen.
Kapitel 25.
Die Menschen, sagte der kleine Prinz, drängen sich in Schnellzüge,
aber sie wissen nicht wohin sie wollen.
So fahren sie hin und her und dabei immer im Kreis.
Und er fügt ihn zu.
Das ist es nicht wert.
Der Brunnen, zu dem wir kamen, sah nicht so aus wie die üblichen Sahara-Brunnen.
Die Brunnen in der Sahara sind nur einfache Löcher im Sand.
Dieser aber, glicch einem Dorfbrunnen.
Aber da war kein Dorf und ich glaubte zu träumen.
Merkwürdig, sagte ich zum kleinen Prinzen.
Alles ist bereit. Die Winde, der Eimer, das Seil.
Er lachte, faste das Seil und ließ die Brunnen Winde spielen.
Und sie ächzte wie ein alter Wetterhahn, wenn der Wind lange geschlafen hat.
Herr Esther, sagte der kleine Prinz, wer wecken diesen Brunnen und er singt?
Ich wollte nicht, dass er sich zu sehr anstrengt.
Lass mich das machen, sagte ich.
Das ist so schwer für dich.
Langsam zog ich den Eimer bis zum Rand hinauf.
Ich stellte ihn ganz aufrecht hin.
In meinen Ohren halte noch das geräuschte Zugwinde.
Und im zitternden Wasser sah ich die Sonne schimmern.
Mich dürstet es nach diesem Wasser, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Gib mir zu trinken.
Und ich verstand, was er gesucht hatte.
Ich hob den Eimer an seine Lippen.
Er trank mit geschlossenen Augen.
Das war köstlich, wie ein Fest.
Dieses Wasser war alles andere als ein einfaches Lebensmittel.
Es war ein Standen aus dem Marsch unter den Sternen.
Das war ein Gesang der Brunnenwinde.
Aus der Anstrengung meiner Arme.
Es tat dem Herzen so gut wie ein Geschenk.
Genauso machten, als ich ein kleiner Junge war,
das Licht des Weihnachtsbaums, die Musik der Mitternachtsmesse,
die Milde des Lächelns, den ganzen Zauber des Geschenks aus,
das ich bekam.
Die Menschen bei dir, sagte der kleine Prinz,
sie fanden 5.000 Rosen im gleichen Garten.
Und sie finden nicht, wonach sie suchen.
Sie finden es nicht, antwortete ich.
Und dabei könnte man das, was sie suchen,
in einer einzigen Rose, oder in ein wenig Wasser finden.
Natürlich, antwortete ich.
Und der kleine Prinz ergänzte.
Aber die Augen sind blind.
Man muss mit dem Herzen suchen.
Ich hatte getrunken.
Ich atmete tief durch.
Der Sand hat bei Tagesanbruch die Farbe von Honig.
Ich war glücklich über diese Honigfarbe.
Warum musste ich traurig sein?
Du musst dein Versprechen halten,
sagte der kleine Prinz Sanft,
die sich wieder neben mich gesetzt hatte.
Welches Versprechen?
Du weißt, ein Maulkorb für mein Schaf.
Ich bin verantwortlich für diese Blume.
Ich holte aus meiner Tasche meine Zeichenentwürfe hervor.
Der kleine Prinz sah sie und sagte lachend,
Deine Affenbrotbräume sehen ein bisschen so aus wie Kohlköpfe.
Oh, ich war so stolz auf die Affenbrotbräume gewesen.
Dein Fuchs, seine Ohren, sie sehen ein bisschen wie Hauner aus.
Sie sind so lang.
Und wieder lachte er.
Du bist ungerecht, kleiner Karl.
Ich konnte schon immer nur offene und geschlossene Riesen-Schlangen zeichnen.
Oh, das wird schon gehen, sagte er.
Die Kinder verstehen es.
Ich krizelte also einen Maulkorb.
Und mein Herz zog sich zusammen, als ich ihm die Zeichnung gab.
Du hast etwas vor, von dem ich nichts weiß.
Aber er antwortete mir nicht.
Er sagte, weißt du, mein falser Erde.
Morgen jährt er sich.
Und nach einem Moment stille, sagte er noch.
Mein Absturz, der ereignete sich hier, ganz in der Nähe.
Und wieder fühlte ich einen merkwürdigen Schmerz, ohne zu verstehen, warum.
Währenddessen fiel mir eine Frage ein.
Also ist es kein Zufall, dass du an dem Morgen, an dem ich dich traf, so ganz allein,
tausend Meilen von besiedeltem Gebiet entfernt spazieren gingst.
Du bist zu der Stelle zurückgekehrt, wohin du gefallen warst.
Der kleine Prinz errötete.
Und zögern fügte ich hinzu.
Vielleicht wegen des Jahrestags?
Der kleine Prinz errötete wieder.
Er antwortete nie auf Fragen, aber wenn man rot wird, dann heißt das doch ja, oder?
Ach, sagte ich, ich habe Angst.
Aber er antwortete, du musst jetzt arbeiten.
Du musst zurück zu deiner Maschine.
Ich warte hier auf dich.
Komm morgen Abend wieder.
Aber ich konnte mich nicht beruhigen.
Ich erinnerte mich an den Fuchs.
Es kann passieren, dass man ein bisschen weinen muss,
wenn man sich erzählen lassen.
Kapitel 26.
Neben dem Brunnen stand eine alte Steinmauer.
Als ich am Abend darauf von meiner Arbeit zurückkam,
sah ich von weitem den kleinen Prinzen darauf sitzen,
seine Beine baumelten herab.
Und ich hörte ihn reden.
Du erinnerst dich also nicht?
sagte er.
Es ist nicht ganz genau hier.
Eine andere Stimme musste ihm geantwortet haben,
denn er erwiderte, doch doch, es ist der Tag, aber hier ist nicht der Ort.
Ich ging weiter auf die Mauer zu.
Ich sah und hörte noch immer niemanden.
Trotzdem wiederholte der kleine Prinz noch einmal.
Natürlich, du wirst sehen, wo meine Spur im Sand beginnt.
Du brauchst dort nur auf mich zu warten.
Heute Nacht werde ich dort sein.
Ich war noch 20 Meter von der Mauer weg und ich sah noch immer nichts.
Nach einem kurzen Schweigen, sagte der kleine Prinz,
du hast gutes Gift?
Bist du sicher, mich nicht lange leiden zu lassen?
Ich bleib stehen.
Das Herz zog sich in mir zusammen, aber noch immer verstand ich nicht.
Verschwende jetzt, sagte er.
Ich will er wieder runter.
So senkte ich selbst die Augen hinab an den Fuß der Mauer und sprang zur Seite.
Da war eine dieser gelben Schlangen, die euch in 30 Sekunden töten
und sie regte sich dem kleinen Prinzen entgegen.
Ich wühlte in meiner Tasche nach meinem Revolver.
Ich begann zu rennen, aber durch den Lärm, den ich machte,
ließ ich die Schlange sanft in den Sand gleiten,
wie ein Wasserstrahl, der versiegt.
Und ganz ohne Eile schlüpfte sie zwischen die Steine
und klirrte dabei wie Metall.
Gerade rechtzeitig schaffte ich es zur Mauer,
um meinen kleinen Kerl von einem Prinzen, der bleich wie Schnee war,
in die Arme zu nehmen.
Was ist das für eine Geschichte? Sprichst du jetzt mit Schlangen?
Ich hatte ihm seinen goldenen Schal abgebunden.
Ich habe ihm Wasser an die Schleifen getupft und ihn zu trinken gegeben.
Und dann traute ich mich nicht, ihn noch etwas zu fragen.
Er blickte mich ernst an und legte mir seine Arme um den Hals.
Ich fühlte wie sein Herz schlug, wie das eines starbenden Vogels,
auf den man mit einem Gewehr geschossen hat.
Er sagte, ich bin froh, dass du den Fehler an deiner Maschine finden konntest.
Du wirst nach Hause fahren können.
Woher weißt du das?
Gerade wollte ich ihm sagen, dass mir die Reparatur
trotz aller Hoffnungslosigkeit gelohnt war.
Er erwiderte nichts auf meine Frage, aber er fügte hinzu.
Ich kehre heute auch nach Hause zurück.
Und dann melancholisch.
Das ist um einiges weiter.
Um einiges schwieriger.
Ich fühlte, dass etwas Außergewöhnliches passierte.
Ich hielt ihn feste Marmen wie ein kleines Kind
und dennoch schien es mir, als glitt er senkrecht in einen Abgrund,
ohne dass ich ihm stande, bei ihm zurückzuhalten.
Sein ernster Blick verlor sich, weit weg.
Ich habe dein Schaf.
Ich habe die Giste für das Schaf.
Und ich habe den Maulkorb.
Und er lächelte melancholisch.
Ich wartete lange.
Ich fühlte, wie er immer wärmer wurde.
Kleiner Mann, du hattest Angst.
Er hatte Angst, ganz sicher.
Aber er lächelte sanftmütig.
Heute Abend hätte ich erst richtig Angst haben.
Wieder erstarrte ich, war gelähmt durch das Gefühl von etwas Unwiderruflichen.
Und ich verstand, dass ich die Vorstellung nicht ertrug,
nie wieder dieses Lachen zu hören.
Es war für mich wie ein Brunnen in der Wüste.
Kleiner Kerl, ich will dich noch lachen hören.
Aber er sagte,
in dieser Nacht hat es ein Jahr her sein.
Mein Stern hat sich genau über der Stelle befinden,
an der ich im letzten Jahr heruntergefallen bin.
Kleiner Kerl, ist diese Geschichte von der Schlange
und der Verabredung mit dem Stern nicht mal ein böser Traum.
Aber er antwortete nicht auf meine Frage.
Er sagte,
das, was zählt, sieht man nicht.
Natürlich.
Es ist so wie mit der Blume.
Wenn du eine Blume liebst, die auf einem Stern wächst,
ist es schön, nachts in den Himmel zu schauen.
Auf allen Sternen wachsen Blumen.
Natürlich.
Es ist so wie mit dem Wasser, was du mir zu trinken gabst.
War wie Musik, wegen der Rolle und der Salz.
Erinnerst du dich?
Es war köstlich.
Natürlich.
Du wirst nachts die Sterne beobachten.
Mein Stern ist so klein,
dass ich dir nicht zeigen kann, wo genauer sich befindet.
Es ist besser so.
Mein Stern wird einer der Sterne für dich sein.
So wirst du alle Sterne gerne anschauen.
So, dass wir alle werden deine Freunde sein.
Dann werde ich dir ein Geschenk machen.
Wieder lacht er, kleiner Kerl.
Kleiner Kerl, ich liebe dieses Lachen.
Genau das wird mein Geschenk sein.
Es wird so sein wie mit dem Wasser.
Was meinst du?
Die Menschen haben nicht die gleichen Sterne.
Die Reisen dienen die Sterne als Geleit.
Für andere sind es nur kleine Lichtpunkte.
Für wieder andere, für die Gelehrten stellen sie Probleme dar.
Für mein Geschäftsmann waren sie Gold.
Aber alle diese Sterne schweigen.
Du wirst Sterne haben wie keiner's Erd.
Was willst du sagen?
Wenn du nachts in den Himmel schaust,
wird es für dich sein als Lachten alle Sterne,
weil ich auf einem von ihnen wohn werde.
Weil ich auf einem von ihnen lachen werde.
Du wirst Sterne haben, die lachen können.
Und wieder lachte er.
Und wenn du Trost gefunden hast,
denn man findet immer Trost, wirst du glücklich sein,
mich gekannt zu haben.
Du wirst immer mein Freund sein.
Du wirst Lust haben, mit mir zu lachen.
Und du wirst manchmal dein Fenster öffnen,
einfach so aus Freude.
Und deine Freunde werden erstaunt sein,
als sie dich lachen sehen, wenn du zum Himmel schaust.
Und du wirst ihnen sagen,
ja, beim Anblick der Sterne muss ich immer lachen.
Und sie werden dich für verrückt halten.
Damit werde ich dir einen gemeinen Streich gespielt haben.
Er lachte wieder.
Es wird sein, als hätte ich dir,
ein Haufen Glöckchen geschenkt, die lachen können.
Wieder lachte er.
Dann aber wurde er ernst.
Heute Nacht, weißt du,
komm nicht.
Ich werde dich nicht verlassen.
Es wird so aussehen, als hätte ich Schmerzen.
Es wird ein bisschen so aussehen, als müsste ich sterben.
So ist das.
Komm dir das nicht anschauen, das ist nicht nötig.
Ich werde dich nicht verlassen.
Aber er war besorgt.
Ich sage dir das auch wegen der Schlange.
Sie soll dich nicht beißen, Schlangen sind bösartig.
Die beißen auch zum Spaß.
Ich werde dich nicht verlassen, etwas beruhigte ihn.
Sie haben nicht ausreichend Gift für einen zweiten Bes.
In dieser Nacht habe ich nicht gesehen,
wie er sich auf den Weg machte.
Er ging fort, ohne Lärm zu machen.
Als ich ihn einholte, liefer er entschlossen mit schnellem Schritt vorwärts.
Er sagte mir nur,
Ha, da bist du.
Und er nahm mich bei der Hand.
Aber quält er sich noch.
Du hast nicht recht getan.
Es wird traurig sein.
Es wird aussehen, als sei ich tot, aber das wird nicht stimmen.
Ich schwieg.
Du verstehst, dass es zu weit ist.
Ich kann diesen Körper hier nicht mitnehmen.
Er ist zu schwer.
Ich schwieg.
Ich werde wie eine alte, übrig gebliebene Hülle sein.
Das ist doch nichts Trauriges.
So eine Hülle.
Ich schwieg.
Er verlor ein bisschen den Mut.
Aber strengte sich doch noch einmal an.
Es wird fröhlich sein.
Auch ich werde die Sterne betrachten.
Alle Sterne werden wie Brunnen sein.
Mit einer verrosteten Winde.
Alle Sterne werden mir zu trinken geben.
Ich schwieg.
Es wird so lustig sein.
Du wirst 500 Millionen Glöckchen haben.
Ich werde 500 Millionen Brunnen haben.
Dann schwieg auch er, denn er weinte.
Dort ist es.
Lass mich alleine einen Schritt machen.
Und ersetzte sich hin, denn er hatte Angst.
Er sagte, weißt du, meine Blume,
ich bin für sie verantwortlich.
Und sie ist so schwach.
Sie ist so leichtgläubig.
Sie hat nur vier lächerliche Dornen,
um sich gegen die Welt zu schützen.
Ich setzte mich, denn ich konnte mich nicht mehr aufrecht halten.
Ich sagte, das ist alles.
Er zögerte noch kurz.
Dann stand er auf.
Er machte einen Schritt.
Ich konnte mich nicht rühren.
Es blitzte nur gelb, ganz nah an seinem Knöchel.
Einen Augenblick lang erstarrte er.
Er schrie nicht.
Er fiel sanft um wie ein Baum.
Durch den Sand war nicht mal ein Geräusch zu hören.
Kapitel 27.
Und jetzt ist das schon sechs Jahre her.
Ich habe diese Geschichte noch nie erzählt.
Meine Kameraden, die mich zu Gesicht bekamen,
waren sehr glücklich, mich lebend wiederzusehen.
Ich war traurig.
Aber sagte zu ihnen, das ist die Erschöpfung.
Jetzt habe ich mich wieder erster.
Das heißt, nicht ganz.
Aber ich weiß, dass er auf seinem Planeten gelandet ist.
Denn bei Tagesanbruch habe ich seinen Körper nicht wiedergefunden.
So schwer war sein Körper wohl nicht.
Und ich liebe es, nachts den Sternen zu zu hören.
Sie sind wie 500 Millionen Glöckchen.
Aber etwas Außergewöhnliches geht vor sich.
Ich habe mich wieder erstaunlich gefühlt.
Und das geht vor sich.
An dem Maulkorb, den ich für den kleinen Prinzen gezeichnet habe,
habe ich den Lederriemen vergessen.
Er wird sein Schaf niemals anbinden können.
So frage ich mich, was ist auf seinem Planeten geschehen?
Vielleicht hat das Schaf doch die Blume gefressen.
Mal sage ich mir, bestimmt nicht.
Der kleine Prinz schützt die Blume jede Nacht unter ihrer Glasglocke
und hat ein wachsames Auge auf das Schaf.
Dann bin ich glücklich.
Und alle Sterne lächeln sanft.
Mal sage ich mir, manchmal ist man ja etwas zerstreut
und das allein reicht schon.
Er wird eines Abends die Glasglocke vergessen haben.
Oder das Schaf ist nachts lautlos ausgebrochen.
Dann werden die Glocken zu tränen.
Darin liegt das große Geheimnis.
Für euch, die ihr den kleinen Prinzen auch liebt,
gilt ebenso wie für mich, dass nichts auf der Welt gleich bleibt.
Wenn irgendwo, man weiß nicht mal wo,
ein Schaf, das wir nicht kennen, eine Blume gefressen hat.
Oder aber nicht.
Schaut euch den Himmel an.
Fragt euch, hat das Schaf die Blume gefressen?
Oder nicht.
Und ihr werdet sehen, wie sich alles verändert.
Und kein Erwachsener wird jemals verstehen,
welche große Bedeutung das hat.
Dies hier ist für mich die schönste und die traurigste Landschaft der Welt.
Es ist die gleiche Landschaft wie auf dem vorigen Bild.
Aber ich habe sie noch einmal gezeichnet, um sie euch noch besser zu zeigen.
Hier ist der kleine Prinz auf die Erde gekommen
und wieder verschwunden.
Schaut euch die Landschaft genau an, damit ihr sie sicher wieder erkennt,
wenn ihr eines Tages durch die afrikanische Wüste reißt.
Und wenn ihr dort vorbeikommt, ich bitte euch, dann nehmt euch Zeit.
Wartet ein bisschen unter dem Stern.
Wenn ein Kind zu euch kommt, wenn es lacht
und wenn es goldene Haare hat, wenn es nicht antwortet,
wenn man es ausfragt, dann wisst ihr schon, wer es ist.
Also, seid freundlich.
Lasst mich nicht weiter traurig sein.
Schreibt mir schnell, dass er zurückgekommen ist.